SUBCOMMITTEE FORESTED
ADMINISTRATION WE'VE TO OUT OF
THE FOLLOWING CALENDAR AND
FIFTEEN ITEMS TO BE HEARD.
WE WERE ROLL CALL DISTURBS
CORDLESS COOPER HERE CHIU.
LACKEY NAZARIAN WICKS.
KEVIN MOTION ON THE ONLY
CALENDAR.
OKAY ROLL CALL PLEASE COOPER
[inaudible]
HI -- TO LACKEY NAZARIAN CLICKS.
GET TEXAS WERE FIRST I'M A
BUSINESS THAT WILL BE -- THE
NUMBER ONE ASSEMBLY HOUSING
HOMELESS PROPOSAL.
ISSUE ONE OUTLINES THE ASSEMBLY
HOUSING HOMELESS PRIORITIES
THESE PRIORITIES REFLECT
FEEDBACK FROM BOTH MEMBERS AND
STAKEHOLDERS.
WE EXPECT TO CONTINUE THIS
DISCUSSION AS WE HEAD INTO THE
MAY REVISE THIS PROPOSAL WORSE
THAN THE FRAMEWORK OF THE
GOVERNOR'S JANUARY BUDGET.
INCLUDING USING THE MOST PART.
THE SAME FUNDING LEVELS.
HIGHLIGHTS INCLUDE FOR THE
PLANNING OF PRODUCTION GRANTS
THERE'S AN EMPHASIS ON NOT USING
TRANSPORTATION FUNDING.
INCLUDING SB ONE IN FOCUSING THE
FIVE OR MILLION SAID FUNDING
SPECIFICALLY ON HOUSING
INFRASTRUCTURE. FOR HOMELESSNESS
HE SIMPLY PROPOSES TO INCREASE
THE FUNDING FROM FIVE HUNDRED TO
SIX SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS IN
THESE THE HOMELESS EMERGENCY A
PROGRAM.
WHICH WAS ESTABLISHED LAST YEAR
IN THE BUDGET.
THE HEAT PROGRAM INCLUDE
FLEXIBILITY WHICH BASED ON INPUT
IS SOMETHING THAT LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS LIKE FROM LAST
YEAR.
UNDER TAX CREDITS SELECT THE
GOVERNOR IS SIMPLY PROPOSAL
SUPPORT EXPANDING THE LOW INCOME
HOUSING TAX CREDIT.
PROGRAM UTILIZED THE 4% CREDITS.
FINALLY THE ASSEMBLY PLAN THE
FIRST IS THE CORPORAL SOUL TO
THE POLICY PROCESS.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
MEMBERS.
THIS WEEK'S -- THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR FOR THE PRESENTATION I AM
PLEASED WITH THE FRAMEWORK
THAT'S MOVING FORWARD AND HAVE A
BIG INTEREST EXPANDING.
KEEP IN PARTICULAR THE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS -- AS YOU MAY KNOW
I DO HAVE A BILL THAT CREATES A
STATEWIDE STANDARDIZED FORMAT
FOR REPORTING.
THE CRITICAL THAT ON THE
HOMELESSNESS THAT WE NEED TO
THINK TO SOLVE THE THE PROBLEM --
SO FROM MY PERSPECTIVE IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT -- WE INCLUDE
DATA COLLECTION ON THE FOLLOWING
THINGS -- HOMELESSNESS
DEMOGRAPHICS -- ABILITY AND
RESOURCE ALLOCATION.
THE CURRENT PROJECTED SUPPLY
VERY SICK COMBINATION UNITS FOR
HOMELESSNESS AND HOUSING AND
SECURE POPULATIONS -- AND THE
NUMBER PERMITS SUPPORT OF
HOUSING UNITS EXTREMELY LOW
HOUSING UNITS AND EMERGENCY
SHELTER BEDS WITHIN EACH COUNTY.
I THINK THAT THE MORE WE COLLECT
THIS DATA THE MORE THAT WE HAVE
STANDARDIZED DATA WE CAN THEN
FIGURE OUT HOW DO WE ADDRESS --
AND SOUL FOR THE PROBLEM THAT I
KNOW FACES MANY OF OUR
COMMUNITIES I KNOW MY DISTRICT
WE HAVE ABOUT A 40% INCREASE IN
HOMELESS AS THE LAST TWO YEARS --
SITTING HAVING THAT KIND OF
STANDARDIZED DATA -- WILL BE
HELPFUL FOR US.
THANK YOU MISTER.
TO LET ME FIRST START BY
THANKING BOTH THE ADMINISTRATION
AS WELL AS OUR BUDGET COMMITTEE
FOR MOVING FOR THESE PROPOSAL
CERTAINLY THE LEVEL OF FUNDING
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
I THINK IT'S ENTIRELY
APPROPRIATE AND I VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT HAS
GONE INTO THIS FRAMEWORK FROM
THE ASSEMBLY SIDE INTO HOPE THAT --
WE WILL HAVE FRUITFUL
CONVERSATIONS BETWEEN OUR TWO
BRANCHES A FEW THINGS THAT I
JUST WANNA MENTION FROM MY
STANDPOINT -- HALF A BILLION
DOLLARS FOR LOW INCOME HOUSING
TAX CREDIT -- WE CERTAINLY NEED
THAT -- THE ONE THING I WOULD
SAY IS MY HOPE IS THAT IT'S NOT
JUST ABOUT INCREASING THE AMOUNT
OF THE CREDIT FOR ONE YEAR
BECAUSE WE KNOW THERE'S ENOUGH
DEMAND TODAY TO USE THE ENTIRE
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
IT'S BEEN PROPOSED IN THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET -- BUT AS I'VE
BEEN PROPOSING FOR NUMBER OF
YEARS AND I THINK THERE'S
TREMENDOUS SUPPORT AROUND THE
STATE WIDE.
IN OUR HOUSING.
DEVELOPMENT COMMUNITY.
WE NEED TO HAVE AN ON GOING
BASIS FOR AN INCREASE IN THE TAX
CREDIT WE KNOW THAT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPERS ARE PLANNING
THEIR FINANCING YEARS IN ADVANCE
WE KNOW THAT BANKS.
THAT PURCHASED THESE TAX CREDITS
DO -- PLANNING YEARS IN ADVANCE
AND THEY NEED TO KNOW WHAT TAX
CREDITS ARE AVAILABLE IT'S
IMPORTANT PROVIDE SOME
PREDICTABILITY TO THE MARKET
PLACE AND I THINK THAT WE NEED
TO THINK ABOUT.
HOW WE MAKE THE TAX RATE ON
GOING -- I WANNA SAY WITH
REGARDS -- TO THE MONEY THAT'S
BEING PROPOSED FOR MISSING
MIDDLE PRODUCTION IT IS.
AN AREA THAT I WOULD SUPPORT I
WOULD JUST MENTION -- THAT WE
HAVE HAD A PROPOSAL FOR A NUMBER
OF YEARS TO HELP AND SENT
MISSING MIDDLE PRODUCTION
THROUGH AB -- SEVENTEEN THIRTY
FOUR THAT WOULD -- PROPOSE A
PROPERTY TAX WELL FOR EXEMPTION
IN RETURN FOR A COMMITMENT --
THAT A DEVELOPER BE ABLE TO
DEVELOP -- RENTS AND OR OR
PRODUCTION THAT -- INVOLVES
UNITS WITH RENTS BELOW MARKET
RATE I THINK THAT'S THE SORT OF
STRUCTURE WE MAY WANT TO
CONSIDER GIVING THAT THIS IS
PRODUCTION -- THAT WOULD NOT
LEVERAGE OTHER TYPES OF FUNDING.
WITH REGARDS TO THE INCREASE
HOMELESSNESS DOLLARS -- THERE
WERE DISCUSSING CERTAINLY AGAIN
SUPPORT THE AMOUNT OF FUNDING
BUT I'LL JUST POINT OUT THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT AGAIN ONE
TIME FUNDING.
AND EMERGENCY RESPONSE TO
HOMELESSNESS WHEN WE KNOW THAT
HOMELESSNESS IS NOT SOMETHING
THAT'S GOING TO GET SOLVED
OVERNIGHT AND I THINK WE NEED TO
THINK A BIT MORE STRATEGICALLY
ABOUT THIS -- AS FAR AS A MANY
THE HE PROGRAM AND I DO
APPRECIATE THE FOCUS ON THE
PROGRAM.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
MAINTAIN FOR FLEXIBILITY BUT WE
ALSO FOCUS ON EVIDENCE SPACES
EVIDENCE BASED APPROACHES TO
HOMELESSNESS THAT WORK.
LONG TERM RENTAL ASSISTANCE
PROJECT BASED HOUSING VOUCHERS
TIED TO SUPPORT OF HOUSING.
OPERATING SUBSIDIES FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS
AND EMERGENCY SHELTERS IN
ADDITIONAL IN ADDITION A FUNNY
NAVIGATION CENTERS.
WE HAVE TO THINK OF HOW WE T<c.cyan></c>
PROGRAM FUNDS TO OUTCOMES IT
MOVE PEOPLE TO PERMANENT HOUSING
SOLUTIONS.
AND I THINK FOCUS A GOOD CHUNK
OF THIS MONEY ON CHRONICALLY
HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS AND THEN I
WOULD JUST ECHO WHAT -- MS WICKS
JUST SAID ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE
OF COLLECTING DATA I KNOW THAT --
WE HAVE BEEN TALKING FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS AND EIGHT CD IS
TRYING TO MOVE FORWARD WITH -- A
STATE DATA WAREHOUSE SO THAT WE
COORDINATE STATE ILLEGAL RE
LOCAL RESOURCES TO RESPOND
HOMELESSNESS I ALSO THINK WE
HAVE TO FULLY STAFF THE HOMELESS
FINANCING AND COORDINATING
COUNCIL SO THEY CAN REALLY FOR
FILL THEIR ROLE.
ON ON BOTH OF THOSE RESPECTS ONE
LAST THING I WANT TO MENTION IS.
THERE IS MONEY FOR PLANNING AND
PRODUCTION GRANTS THAT I SUPPORT
AND I APPRECIATE THE STRUCTURE
THAT'S BEEN PROPOSED BY THE
GOVERNOR AND CONFIRMED AND THIS
FRAMEWORK. ONE WEEK I WOULD ASK
FOR IT IS THERE ARE TRANSIT
AGENCIES THAT ARE ALSO WORKING --
TO HELP ADDRESS THE HOUSING
CHALLENGES THAT WE HAVE LAST
YEAR OUR GOVERNOR SIGNED AB
TWENTY NINE TWENTY THREE WHICH
WOULD ALLOW FOR FOR EXAMPLE --
THE BAY AREA PART SYSTEM TO
THINK ABOUT ITS LAND AND
PRODUCING HOUSING ON TOP OF ITS
LAND.
IT IS IN NEED OF PLANNING
DOLLARS IN THE WAY THAT OTHER --
COGS IN LOCAL JURISDICTIONS ARE
IN NEED OF PLANNING DOLLARS MY
HOPE IS THERE SOME FLEXIBILITY
WHEN IT COMES -- TO THE SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS OF
PLANNING A PRODUCTION GRANTS TO
ASSIST AGENCIES INVOLVED IN THAT
DISCUSSION BUT ALL THAT BEING
SAID.
I THINK WHAT HAS BEEN SKETCH OUT
HERE WITH THE ASSEMBLY FRAMEWORK
MAKES A LOT OF SENSE AND VERY
MUCH LOOK FOR TO THE
CONVERSATION WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE ON THIS.
THANK YOU THIS TIME WE'LL OPEN
UP THE PUBLIC COMMENT.
ANYONE WISH TO SPEAK ON THIS
ITEM.
JOSH DUGGAR REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES -- RELATIVE TO THE
HOUSING PROPOSAL SEE SACK
SUPPORT THE COMMITTEE'S PROPOSAL
TO ALLOCATE REGIONAL AND LOCAL
GRANT FUNDING FOR IMPLEMENTING
CURRENT HOUSING PLANNING
REQUIREMENTS WE ALSO SUPPORT
FOCUSING THE FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION FOR INFRASTRUCTURE
NEEDED TO SUPPORT.
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
IN ALL COMMUNITIES AND RELATIVE
TO THE HOMELESSNESS PROPOSAL I
WE WERE SUPPORT THE MOVEMENT
TOWARDS THE FLEXIBILITY OF LAST
YEAR'S HE PROGRAM OR THIS YEAR'S
HE PROGRAM -- WE THINK THAT
GIVING LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
MAXIMUM FLEXIBILITY TO IMPLEMENT --
PROJECTS AND SERVICES LIKE
CONNECTING INDIVIDUALS TO
SUPPORT SERVICES AND RAPID RE
HOUSING AND RENTAL ASSISTANCE
PROGRAMS WILL LEAD TO MAXIMUM
SUCCESS -- WE ALSO SUPPORT
COUNTY LED TO EFFORTS TO LOOK AT
SYSTEM -- SYSTEM LEVEL
IMPROVEMENTS TO THE HOMELESSNESS --
CRISIS -- BUT TO THE EXTENT THAT
WE CONTINUE TO ALLOCATE FUNDS
THROUGH THE C. O. C. MODEL WE
WOULD.
LIKE TO CONTINUE TO PARTNER WITH
YOU AND STAFF ON IMPLEMENTING
CHANGES TO THESE A CONTINUUM OF
CARE MODEL THAT PROVIDE AN ACT
VOTE EQUITABLE ACCESS TO FUNDS
FOR THOSE SYSTEM LEVEL
IMPROVEMENTS AND MORE
COLLABORATION.
AND LASTLY IN THE SPIRIT OF THE
COLLABORATION -- WE WOULD BE
CONCERNED ABOUT ANY INCREASING
PROPORTIONATE SHARE OF CARVE
OUTS AS WE THINK THAT THIS
COLLABORATIVE PROCESS IS WHAT
WILL LEAD TO BETTER OUTCOMES.
AND ANALYST AT LASTLY BUT WE DO
SUPPORT THE USE OF TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN POINT IN TIME COUNTS
FOR ANY AS THE UNDERLYING DATA
FOR ANY MATT ALLOCATION
METHODOLOGIES THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU.
NICOLE ORNAMENT ON BEHALF OF THE
SAN BERNADINO COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS WE REALLY APPRECIATE
THE ASSEMBLY PROPOSAL FOR
ADDITIONAL HOMELESSNESS FUNDING --
LAST YEAR HEAP SPARKED THE
DEVELOPMENT OF PARTNERSHIPS AND
MULTI JURISDICTIONAL
COLLABORATIONS WITHIN THE COUNTY.
THAT HAVE BEEN HELPFUL DESPITE
THE ONGOING NEEDS THE REGION HAS
SEEN POSITIVE CHANGES AS A
RESULT OF INVESTMENTS IN
PROGRAMS.
SUCH AS PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING HOMELESS OUT REACH AN
AGGRESSIVE USE OF HOUSING FIRST
AND RAPID RE HOUSING PROTOCOLS.
WE WOULD ENCOURAGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO ALSO USE THE TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN POINT IN TIME
COUNT ONE TO ENSURE FLEXIBILITY
ON HOW THE DOLLARS ARE USED.
AND WOULD SUPPORT INTRODUCING
THE CONCEPT OF REWARDING
JURISDICTIONS FOR INNOVATIVE OR
CREATIVE PROJECTS TO
SUCCESSFULLY ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS THANK YOU.
HI I'M DAVID SISTER WITH HOUSING
CALIFORNIA FOR PART OF MY
COMMENTS ALSO BE SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF OTHER CORPORATION FOR
SUPPORT OF HOUSING.
I'LL BE TALKING ABOUT THE
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS PIECES --
PERSONAL WE APPRECIATE HAVING
BOTH THE GOVERNOR AND THE
LEGISLATURE SO FOCUSED ON
HOUSING.
THIS PROPOSAL OF COURSE INCLUDES
SOME VERY IMPORTANT ELEMENTS
INCLUDING AN EXPANSION OF TAX
CREDITS.
AND INVESTMENT IN INFRASTRUCTURE.
AT THE SAME TIME THIS PROPOSAL
DOES NEED SOME REFINEMENT OF
BOTH MORE EQUITABLY AND MORE
DIRECTLY SERVE THOSE MOST IN
NEED. EIGHT CITIES ON DATA SHOWS
THAT OF THE SHORTFALL OF THREE
AND A HALF MILLION HIGH RENTAL
HOMES. 71% IS FOR VERY LOW AN
EXTREMELY LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS
WHILE JUST 2% IS FOR MODERATE
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS.
YEAH THIS PROPOSAL DIVERT SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION TOWARDS
PLANNING AN INFRASTRUCTURE AND
SEVEN HUNDRED MILLION TOWARDS
THE MIXED INCOME PROGRAM -- THE
MIX INTO PROGRAM WHILE IMPORTANT
DIVER -- IS A PILOT THAT HASN'T
BEEN FULLY TESTED YET -- TOOK
APPLICATIONS FOR FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS JUST RECENTLY AND AS I
UNDERSTAND IT HAS NOT YET
ALLOCATED FUNDS.
THE ONLY PLACE WHERE LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS GET DIRECT INVESTMENT
IN AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT IN THE BUDGET.
IS THE THREE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR PORTION OF THE TAX CREDIT
EXPANSION.
AND WHILE THESE ARE ALL SMART
INVESTMENTS THEY'D THEY NEED TO
BE MADE MORE EQUITABLY AND MORE
PROPORTIONATE TO THE NEED --
MOREOVER WE NEED INVESTMENTS
LIKE TAX CREDITS BE ON GOING
INSTEAD OF ONE TIME TO TRULY
ADDRESS THE SCALE OF THE PROBLEM.
WHEN WE FAIL TO STIR FAMILIES OF
THE LOWEST INCOMES WE ONLY GROW
OUR POPULATION EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS?
AND ON THAT NOTE HOUSING
CALIFORNIANS USERS ARE EXCITED
TO SEE CONTINUED INVESTMENT FROM
THE LEGISLATURE TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS.
BUT WE DO HAVE SOME CONCERNS
WITH THE STRUCTURE PROPOSED HERE.
THIS LEGISLATIVE BODY CREATED
THE HOMELESS EMERGENCY AID
PROGRAM LAST YEAR IT WAS
INTENDED TO ADDRESS THE
IMMEDIATE CRISIS OF PEOPLE ON
THE STREETS.
BASICALLY STOPPED OUT BEFORE
FINDING MORE PERMANENT SOLUTIONS.
WE STRONGLY BELIEVE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD ADDRESS THIS
CRISIS IN A MORE SUSTAINABLE AN
EVIDENCE BASED APPROACH -- TO
INTERVENTIONS PRUDENT TO
DECREASE HOMELESSNESS.
THE GOVERNOR HIMSELF STATED THAT
SHELTERS ALL SLEEP.
WELL HOUSING SERVICES SOLVE
HOMELESSNESS IN OTHER WORDS THE
NUMBER ONE SOLUTION HOMELESSNESS
IS A HOME IT'S ALSO THE EVIDENCE
BASED SOLUTION.
WE HOPE THAT AS YOU CONTINUE. TO
TO DEVELOP A RESPONSE TO
HOMELESSNESS THROUGH THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET THE YOU'LL CONSIDER A
MORE HOLISTIC LONG TERM APPROACH
LIKE THE ONE PROPOSED.
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK SILVA
IN AB EIGHT SIXTEEN WE NEED A
BOTH AND STRATEGY KEEP IS ONE
PART OF IT AND WE NEED REAL
INVESTMENT PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING AS WELL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MARINO WHITE WITH
THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
CONSORTIUM APPRECIATE AND
SUPPORT THE FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR ALLOCATION TO THE STATE
TAX RATE PROGRAMS BUT A TOP
PRIORITY OF OUR ORGANIZATION
I'VE BEEN WORKING CLOSELY WITH A
FAMILY MEMBER TO FOR MANY YEARS.
JUST WANT TO ECHO THE COMMENTS
THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO MEET
RELATED TO THE NEED FOR ITS BEEN
ON GOING ALLOCATION IN ADDITION
TO HIS.
HIS THREE MAIN POINTS JUST WANT
TO ADD THAT IN ORDER FOR THE
ANNUAL AMOUNT OF PRODUCTION TO
INCREASE THE ALLOCATION NEEDS TO
BE ON GOING SO DEVELOPERS CAN
ACTUALLY INCREASE THEIR PIPELINE
INSTEAD OF SORT OF MEETING ON AN
ANNUAL BASIS -- THE THE UNITS IN
THEIR PIPELINE THANK YOU.
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CAN LOW'S
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR YOUTH AND REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT ASSEMBLY
LEADERSHIP AROUND HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS ESPECIALLY --
AROUND YOUR RECOMMENDATIONS TO
INCREASE FUNDING FOR THE
HOMELESS RESPONDING TO
HOMELESSNESS PROPOSAL AND
INCREASING AND THE SET ASIDE FOR
YOU.
SPECIFICALLY -- A WE HAVE SEEN
EARLY DATA THAT SAYS ABOUT 7% OF
ALLOCATION CURRENTLY FROM LAST
YEAR'S POT IS GOING FOR ITS
YOUTH WE KNOW IN SOME AREAS THAT
HAVE BEEN HIGHER AND AND MORE.
PROGRESSIVE LIKE IN SAN
FRANCISCO WHERE THEY'RE SPENDING
ABOUT 60% I'M I WOULD ENCOURAGE
YOU TO INCLUDE SOMETHING AROUND
THIS CONTINUUM OF CARE LOOKING
AT TAKING THE RECOMMENDATIONS OF
THE YOUTH SUB COMMITTEES OR
WHATEVER SPECIFIC YOUTH
PROVIDERS.
THAT ARE IN THEIR COMMUNITY AND
WHAT THE PROGRAM SHOULD BE
FUNDED BECAUSE THAT'S NOT ALWAYS
THE CASE AND ENCOURAGE YOU TO
CONSIDER ON GOING FUNDING.
SUCH AS AN ASSEMBLYMEMBER RACES
PROPOSAL WHICH IS PERFORMED
BEFORE YOU BECAUSE WE REALLY
NEED TO SEE.
ONGOING FUNDING SPECIFICALLY
DIRECTED FOR YOUTH BECAUSE IF WE
DON'T WE KNOW THAT WE'RE NEVER
GONNA SOLVE THIS ALMOST AS
PROBLEM BECAUSE OUR YOUTH OF
TODAY WILL BECOME A CHRONIC MOST
POPULATION OF TOMORROW.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR JEAN
HEARST HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE URBAN COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA --
AND THERE IS A LARGE LIKE IN THE
ASSEMBLY IS PROPOSAL AND WE
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THE
CONVERTIBLE INVESTMENT IN THIS
CRITICAL -- AREA I WOULD CONCUR
WITH MY COLLEAGUE FROM THE STATE
pHOMELESS POINTS THAT I JUST
WANTED TO REITERATE AGAIN WE DO --
SUPPORT INVESTMENT IN THAT HE
PROGRAM -- FOR IT OFFERS
FLEXIBILITY AND WE AGREE THAT --
EVIDENCE BASED PRACTICES ARE
APPROPRIATE I IN THAT STRUCTURE.
WE ALSO THINK THAT THE HE
PROGRAM INCENTIVIZE IS
COLLABORATION WHICH WOULD RESULT
IN BETTER OUTCOMES OF LOCALLY
AND WE WOULD CONCUR WITH THAT --
REQUEST USE THE TWENTY NINETEEN
POINT IN TIME COUNTY TO AS THE
BASIS ON WHICH TO ESTABLISH THE
ALLOCATION THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON SHERILYN ADAMS
WITH OUR CONCERT YOU SERVICES IN
SAN FRANCISCO AND TO SEE WHY --
AND I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
ASSEMBLY IS -- ATTENTION AND
FOCUS AND PRIORITIZATION OF
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS FOR ALL
POPULATIONS I FOR THERE REALLY
WOULD LOVE TO SEE HE EXPANDED
OUR THAT INCREASED ALLOCATION
FOR YOUNG PEOPLE IN THEY KEEP
FUNDS WE HAVE USED THE FUNDS TO
GET PEOPLE IMMEDIATELY OFF THE
STREET AND ALSO TO PLACE THEM.
IN RAPID RE HOUSING SO YOUNG
PEOPLE DO SUPER GREAT IN HAVING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR A PORTFOLIO OF
HOUSING OPTIONS AND FLEXIBILITY
AND THAT'S WHAT HE OFFERS AND IT
WILL AND HOMELESSNESS FOR THOSE
YOUNG PEOPLE.
ABOUT TWO HUNDRED OF THEM IN SAN
FRANCISCO THAT WE WILL HOUSE --
OVER THE NEXT EIGHTEEN MONTHS.
WITH USING HEAT FUNDS -- I ALSO
SUPPORT AND I'M GOING ALLOCATION
FOR YOUNG PEOPLE TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS ONE MILLION DOLLARS
IN ONGOING FUNDING.
HAS BEEN THE STATE'S INVESTMENT
TO DATE AND THE ON GOING FUNDS
FOR YOUNG PEOPLE AND WE ACTUALLY
NEED SIGNIFICANTLY MORE TO MAKE
SURE THAT YOUNG PEOPLE UNDER
TWENTY FOUR I'M NOT SLEEPING ON
OUR STREETS HAVE ACCESS TO
HOUSING.
AND OTHER SUPPORT SO THAT THEY
CAN TRANSITION INTO INDEPENDENCE
AND NOT -- BECOME ARE
CHRONICALLY HOMELESS ADULTS
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON TAMMY MARTIN ON
BEHALF OF EQUALITY CALIFORNIA
AND WE THINK THE LEGISLATURE FOR
ITS CONTINUING ATTENTION TO THE
ISSUE OF HOMELESSNESS
PARTICULARLY IN LIGHT OF THE
DISPROPORTIONATE NUMBER OF LGBTQ
YOUTH.
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS AND WE
MAINTAIN OUR REQUESTS THAT THE
ASSEMBLY CONSIDER INCORPORATING
THE PROPOSAL FROM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RAY AS WHICH WOULD ENSURE
DEDICATED RESOURCES ON AN
ONGOING BASIS FOR USE AS
ARTICULATED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON KIANA VALENTINE
ON BEHALF OF TRANSPORTATION
CALIFORNIA WE WOULD BE REMISS TO
NOT BE HERE TODAY TO THANK THE
ASSEMBLY FOR A HOUSING PROPOSAL
THAT DOES NOT INCLUDE THE
LINKING.
OF HOUSING OUTCOMES AND SB ONE
OR ANY TRANSPORTATION DOLLARS SO
OUR GRATITUDE FOR THAT ASPECT OF
THIS PROPOSAL.
AT THAT BEING SAID --
TRANSPORTATION RECOGNIZES WHAT
IT'S LIKE TO BE AND A FUNDING
CRISIS AND SO WE WANT TO BE
SUPPORTIVE OF EFFORTS. TO
ADDRESS THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
CRISIS IN IN THAT VEIN WE ARE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE DIRECTION OF
THE FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
TOWARDS -- INFILL INFRASTRUCTURE
GRANTS AND AND SUPPORTING
HOUSING AND THAT WAY THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON AMY JENKINS ON
BEHALF OF THE ORANGE COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS -- AGAIN
ECHOING PRIOR COMMENTS YOU WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR ON GOING
COMMITMENT TO ADDRESSING HOME AT
THE HOMELESS CRISIS AND WORKING
WITH COUNTIES.
WE APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE'S
PROPOSAL FOR GRANT FUNDING AND
SUPPORT ALLOCATING FUNDS IN THE
CURRENT BUDGET YEAR IN LIEU OF
SETTING ASIDE FUNDS BASED ON
ACHIEVING SPECIFIC MILESTONES.
AND ALLOCATING GRANTS WE REQUEST
FLEXIBILITY TO ALLOCATE HOMELESS.
TO THE COUNTY CEO SEES COUNTY
CEO SEES FISCAL AGENT.
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL WOULD
ALLOCATE GRANTS DIRECTLY TO CO
SEES WILD CEO SEES WERE
ESTABLISHED UNDER FEDERAL LAW
EACH COUNTIES JEEP C. O. C.
JURISDICTION IS STRUCTURED
DIFFERENTLY.
IN ORANGE COUNTY'S AT THEIR CO
C. IS NEITHER ILLEGAL NOR FISCAL
ENTITY.
I COUNTY APPOINTED COMMISSION TO
AND HOMELESSNESS PROVIDES
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS WHICH IS THE
DESIGNATED CO C. FISCAL AGENT --
WE WOULD CONCUR WITH THE PRIOR
COMMENTS AT PERTAINING TO
UTILIZING THE TWENTY NINETEEN
POINT TIME COUNT FOR CURRENT
FUNDING ALLOCATIONS.
LASTLY WE SUGGEST THAT THE SIX
MONTH CAP FOR THE DEFINITION OF
EMERGENCY SHELTER BE ELIMINATED
FROM THE GRANT PROGRAM.
THE AMOUNT OF TIME A HOMELESS
PERSON STAYS IN A SHELTER IS
EXTREMELY INDIVIDUALIZED AND
SHOULD BE DETERMINED LOCALLY
BASED ON AVAILABILITY OF
APPROPRIATE HOUSING OPTIONS
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON BILL HIGGINS WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
COUNCILS OF GOVERNMENTS AND WE
APPRECIATE THE OF FRAMEWORK OF
THE COMMITTEE'S PROPOSAL BUT WE
WANT TO TALK SPECIFICALLY ON THE
HOUSING PLANNING GRANTS AND
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT THE PORTION
GOING TO REGIONAL COUNCILS OF
GOVERNMENTS.
I WANTED TO PAINT A LITTLE BIT
DEEPER PICTURE OF WHAT COULD BE
DONE WITH THOSE FUNDS WE BELIEVE
THAT THE ALLOCATIONS WOULD BE
USED PRIMARILY FOR RE GRANTS FOR
CITIES AND COUNTIES IN LOCATION
EFFICIENT AREAS THAT ARE
CONSISTENT ALSO WITH OUR CLIMATE
GOALS.
COULD ALSO BE USED FOR REGIONAL
HOUSING TRES AND HELPING ARE
LESS EFFICIENT.
ART ARE LESS SMALLER CITIES THAT
DO NOT HAVE NECESSARILY THE THE
THE STAFFING CAPACITY TO HELP
WITH AND IMPROVE THEIR LOCAL
HOUSING POLICIES AND WE WOULD
ALL HAVE LIKE THE THE ECONOMIES
OF SCALE TO PROVIDE THAT.
HERE TO PROVIDE -- MORE DEPTH ON
THAT ARE THE NEXT THREE SPEAKERS
FROM THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION GOVERNMENTS AND
AGAIN S<c.cyan> KHôNG WHO COULD</c>
PROVIDE SOME TOUGH ON THAT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR COOPER AND
MEMBERS OF MY NAME IS CALL MAY I
JUST SAY I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
GOVERNMENTS.
AND I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE
STAFF'S RECOMMENDATION ON OF THE
ASSEMBLY HOUSING AND HOMELESS
FRAMEWORK -- THAT'S ON YOUR
AGENDA TODAY OF THE FRAMEWORK
BASICALLY PROVIDES FOR THE
REGION TO FUND -- TO HELP FUND
CITIES AND AND COUNTIES ARE
REGIONAL GOVERNMENT IN THINKING
STRATEGICALLY ABOUT HOW WE
CREATE AND CREATE MORE HOUSE AND
IN OUR COMMUNITIES --
SPECIFICALLY THE PROPOSAL TO
INCLUDE ON A TWENTY FIVE MILLION
FOR REGIONAL GOVERNMENTS LIKE
SKAGGS -- WILL ALLOW US TO DO TO
CONDUCT FEASIBILITY STUDIES AND
AND SPECIFIC PLANS OF PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE.
TO SOME OF OUR CITIES I DON'T
HAVE THE CAPACITY TO DO THIS AND
AND I THINK I THINK THE OTHER
PART OF IT IS WE US AS BILL SAID
WE HAVE THE ECONOMIES OF SCALE
WE ALREADY HAVE THE DATA IN
PLACE.
AND WE'RE DOING SOME OF HIS WORK
ALREADY USING GENERAL FUND VERY
MEAGER GENERAL FUNDS THAT WE
HAVE I THINK THIS CAPACITY THAT
THIS FUNDING WOULD PROVIDE US.
ALLOWS US TO PROBABLY DO A
LITTLE MORE -- TO STEM -- THE
ISSUE OF HOUSING CRISIS IN OUR
REGIONS AND SO I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR WORK THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CAN GO ON AND THE
CHIEF DEPUTY EXECUTIVE RECTOR
FOR SAN DAGO WANT TO THANK THE
ASSEMBLY FOR THEIR LEADERSHIP ON
THIS -- AS COMING MENTION WHEAT
AND BILL MENTION BEFORE WE DO
SUPPORT THE FRAMEWORK ESPECIALLY
THE FUNDING -- FOR LOCAL FOR
REGIONAL AGENCIES LIKE SAND
AGAINST GAG AND SAY COG -- WE
ARE AN AGENCY THAT HAS STARTED
ARE -- SIX HOUSING ELEMENTS LIKE
OUR SIX RINA CYCLE AND OUR
NUMBERS COMPARED TO THE THE
FIFTH BECAUSE WE NEED TO ALL DO
OUR PART ABOUT 40% HIGHER.
SO WE RECOGNIZE THE CRISIS THAT
WE'RE IN IS THE STATE IN THE
REGION.
THE HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS PASSED ALONG TO THE
REGIONAL GOVERNMENTS WILL LET US
DO THE PLANNING ASSIST OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND BASICALLY PUT
THE RESOURCES IN PLACE WE DON'T
JUST HAVE THESE PLANS WERE ALSO
ABLE THEN. TO IMPLEMENT THEM IN
THE FUTURE SO WE DO SUPPORT AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI CHRISTINA LACKEY WITH THE
SACRAMENTO COUNCIL AREA COUNCIL
OF GOVERNMENTS AND MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS ONE ECHO THE COMMENTS OF
MY COLLEAGUES IN JUST OUT IN THE
SACRAMENTO REGION.
WE'RE IN THE PROCESS OF
DEVELOPING OUR NEXT SUSTAINABLE
COMMITTEE STRATEGY IN AS PART OF
THAT WE'VE IDENTIFIED THIS
YEAR'S NEED TO ACCELERATE INFILL
DEVELOPMENT IN OUR REGION.
SO WE'RE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
PRODUCTION POP PLANNING GRANTS
THAT FRAMEWORK THAT YOU'VE
OUTLINED PARTICULARLY AS IT
RELATES TO INFRASTRUCTURE--
WE'VE DEVELOPED A LOCAL PROGRAM
CALLED GREEN MEANS GO TO
ACCELERATE INFILL -- AND PROP
PRIMARY FOCUS OF THAT IS THE
NEED TO DEVELOP OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE UPGRADE OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE ALONG OLD
COMMERCIAL CORRIDORS.
AREAS THAT WEREN'T BUILT FOR
HIGH DENSITY -- AND SO THERE'S
EXTREME INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS
THERE AND THEN ADDITIONALLY TO
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE LOCATIONAL
EFFICIENCY AS BILL HIGGINS
COMMENTED SO THAT WERE ALSO
MEETING OUR CLIMATE GOALS THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME
IS WESLEY SAVER I'M REPRESENTING
JOHN BURTON ADVOCATES FOR YOUTH
IN SUPPORT OF ISSUE.
ONE SINCE TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
THERE'S BEEN A 39% INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF HOMELESS YOUTH AND
YOUNG ADULTS COMPARED 215% FOR
INDIVIDUALS OVER AGE.
TWENTY FOUR LAST YEAR THE
LEGISLATOR A LEGISLATURE
DEDICATED TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS ONE TIME FUNDING FOR
HOMELESS YOUTH THIS WAS AN
IMPORTANT FIRST STEP.
THE 5% SET ASIDE HOMELESS YOUTH
IS BEING IMPLEMENTED ACROSS
CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA NEEDS MORE NEEDS A
LARGER SET ASIDE FOR ONE TIME
FUNDING IN THE BUDGET IT ALSO
NEEDS AN ONGOING SOLUTION IN
ONGOING INVESTMENT SERVE
HOMELESS YOUTH AND TO PREVENT
ADDITIONAL YOUTH FROM BECOMING
HOMELESS.
I STRONGLY URGE YOU TO INCREASE
THE YOU SET ASIDE THE POSI
FUNDING AND TO ESTABLISH AN
ANNUAL APPROPRIATION TO ADDRESS
YOUTH HOMELESSNESS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THE CHAIR MEMBERS MIKE MULLIGAN
OF YEP THE METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION WE
APPRECIATE THE PROPOSAL THE
FUNDING.
THE FLEXIBILITY IN THE BENEFITS
ALL FLOW TO THE NINE COUNTIES
AND HUNDRED ONE CITIES IN THE
BAY AREA THANK YOU THANK YOU.
STEVE KERR IS ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF SAN JOSE AND MAYOR
LICCARDO -- HERE TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT IMPERSONATION FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL AS WELL AS
THE FRAMEWORK -- SET FORTH BY
THE ASSEMBLY PARTICULARLY WHICH
YOU HEARD FROM PRIOR -- SPEAKERS
THAT FLEXIBILITY OF THE OF THE
PROGRAM AND THEN THE
AUGMENTATION THAT WAS OFFERED
YOUR PROPOSAL SO OF GET
APPRECIATE SPORT [inaudible]
HE CHAIR MEMBERS TRUST BUT THE
ON BEHALF OF SACRAMENTO DEAL
STEINBERG IS FOR THE FRAME
WORKING LIKE THIS A STATE MY
CALL TO THE PREVIOUS SPEAKER AS
RELATES TO THE HE PROGRAM.
THANK YOU.
PERSONALLY CLOSE HERE ON BEHALF
OF LOS ANGELES CITY MAYOR ERIC
GARCETTI WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS
OUR SON SUPPORT FOR SOME LEASE
PROPOSAL ON HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS.
THAT WOULD INCREASE THE FUNDING
TO KEEP IN SPLIT THE FUNDING
EVENLY BETWEEN THE BIG CITY BIG
THIRTEEN CITIES AND THE TEAMS OF
CARE.
LIKE TO ENCOURAGE THE COMMITTEE
TO DISTRIBUTE THE FUNDING
ACCORDING TO NEED.
ARE WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
AND ASSEMBLY LEADERSHIP ON THIS
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
RUNNING VERTICALLY HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA CITIES
JUST WANNA THINK -- THIS
COMMITTEE -- FOR MAKING NO%
CONNECTION TO TRANSPORTATION
FUNDING -- AS PART OF THIS --%
PROCESS AND SO -- APPRECIATE
YOUR LEADERSHIP -- ON THESE
ISSUES AND MAKING MORE RESOURCES
AVAILABLE FOR INFRASTRUCTURE
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
AGAIN THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
COMMENTS PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
REACH OUT TO STAFF AND PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL FEEDBACK.
WE REVISIT THE HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS DISCUSSION AFTER
THE MAY REVISE THE FORTY
CONTINUE DISCUSSION WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS.
I'D BE REMISS BUT AND TALK ABOUT
THE ISSUE OF SUBSTANCE ABUSE AND
MENTAL HEALTH WHEN IT COMES
ALMOST NIS.
AND IF WE DON'T ADDRESS THAT
WILL NEVER TRULY SOLVE THAT
PROBLEM -- KIND OF MOTION
ADOPTED SIMPLY FRAMEWORK ON
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS SO.
SECOND THAT.
THE SECOND ROLL CALL PLEASE.
COOPER HI.
TWO LACKEY MISSOURIAN.
CAN ONE DO ITEM NUMBER TWO OF
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF HE
LET'S
HEAR FROM THE APARTMENT.
GOOD AFTERNOON -- MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE.
ON GINNY PARTY FOR THE EXECUTIVE
OFFICER FOR THE HOMELESS
COORDINATING AND FINANCING
COUNSEL WITH MEALS Là HELLO
MATIX WHO HAS BEEN THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT LIAISON. FOR THE
HOMELESS EMERGENCY AID PROGRAM
SINCE THE PROGRAM'S INCEPTION
AND SHE IS NOW THEY KEEP GRANT
MANAGER.
WE APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
SPEAK WITH YOU ABOUT THE PROGRAM.
OUR REMARKS THIS AFTERNOON WILL
FOCUS ON THE CURRENT STATUS OF
HEAP IMPLEMENTATION AND SOME
EARLY LESSONS LEARNED FROM THE
PROGRAM.
I BELIEVE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE HAVE BEEN PROVIDED
WITH A HIGH LEVEL HEAP TIMELINE.
AS WELL AS A CHART THE PROVIDES
MORE DETAILED INFORMATION ABOUT
THE GRANT APPLICATION PROCESS
AND DISBURSEMENTS.
I WILL TURN NOW TO HELP TO
PROVIDE THE UPDATES ON HEAP
IMPLEMENTATION.
GOOD AFTERNOON AGAIN MY NAME IS
A HELL OF MATIX AND I A THAT
HE'D GRANT MANAGER -- SO AS YOU
KNOW THE HEAT -- PROGRAM WAS
ESTABLISHED IN LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET IT'S A FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR ONE TIME FLEXIBLE
BLOCK GRANT PROGRAM DESIGNED TO
PROVIDE DIRECT ASSISTANCE TO
CITIES.
COUNTIES AND CONTINUES OF CARE
TO ADDRESS THE HOMELESSNESS
CRISIS IN CALIFORNIA.
THE ELIGIBLE APPLICANTS ARE THE
ELEVEN LARGEST CITIES IDENTIFIED
WITH POPULATIONS OF THREE
HUNDRED THIRTY THOUSAND OR MORE
AS OF JANUARY FIRST.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AS WELL AS
THE FORTY THREE CONTINUUM'S OF
CARE.
THE FUNDS ARE ALLOCATED USING A
FORMULA THAT IS BASED LARGELY ON
THAT JURISDICTION'S CHAIR OF THE
STATE'S HOMELESS POPULATION.
OF THE PROGRAM GUIDANCE.
WHICH MAPPED OUT APPLICATION
REQUIREMENTS AN ELIGIBLE
ACTIVITIES -- WAS ISSUED IN
AUGUST OF TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHTEEN FOLLOWED BY THE NOTICE
OF FUNDING AVAILABILITY ON
SEPTEMBER FIFTH -- AND THAT IN
FACT ON SEPTEMBER FIFTH WE
RECEIVED TWO APPLICATIONS FROM
THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO AND THE
CITY OF OAKLAND -- WE ACTUALLY
RECEIVED ALL FORTY THREE
CONTINUES OF CARE AND ELEVEN
LARGE CITY APPLICATIONS BY
DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST -- TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AS REQUIRED IN
STATUTE -- AND THIS IS REALLY
GREAT NEWS BECAUSE THAT MEANT
THAT THERE WAS NOT A SECOND
ROUND OF FUNDING HALL FUNDING
WAS APPLIED FOR IN ROUND.
ONE I'M IN ADDITION YOU CAN SEE
FROM THE HANDOUT THAT YOU HAVE --
THAT WE HAVE EXCEEDED AND MATT
OUR TIME LINES IN THE STATUTE WE
MET OUR INTERNAL GOAL OF
AWARDING HEAT FUNDS WITHIN
FIFTEEN DAYS OF RECEIPT OF A
COMPLETED APPLICATION.
AND THEN WE WERE DISPERSED HE
FUNDS WITHIN FIFTEEN DAYS OF
RECEIPT OF AN EXECUTED STANDARD
AGREEMENT. 41100% OF THESE
GRANTS WE MET OUR COMMITMENT TO
DISPERSE HEAT FUNDS WITHIN SIXTY
DAYS OF THE DATE THE APPLICATION
WAS TEAM TO COMPLETE.
ALL FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
FOR HEAP HAVE BEEN DISPERSED AS
OF APRIL THIRD -- TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN AGAIN THIS IS REALLY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT MEANS THAT
ALL OF THE DOLLARS OFFER HEAP
ARE IN OUR COMMUNITIES -- SO
THAT THEY CAN ADDRESS THE NEEDS
OF HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILIES.
WELL IT'S STILL EARLY IN THE
IMPLEMENTATION PROCESS BASED ON
THE INFORMATION PROVIDED IN THE
STANDARD AGREEMENTS -- THE
CITIES OF THE CEO SEES HAVE
ALLOCATED FINDINGS FUNDING AND
THE GENERAL CATEGORIES AND
SERVICES ABOUT 38% OF THE HEAT
FUNDS -- ARE ALLOCATED TO THAT
CATEGORY 34% FOR CAPITAL
IMPROVEMENT. 13% FOR RENTAL
ASSAULT ASSISTANCE OR SUBSIDIES
7% FOR YOUTH HOMELESSNESS 4% FOR
ADMIN COSTS AND ABOUT 3% IN THE
OTHER CATEGORY WITCHING CAN
INCLUDE THINGS LIKE BATHROOMS
HAND WASHING STATIONS -- SO NOW
THAT THE HEAT FUNDS HAVE BEEN
DISPERSED THE HEAP TEAM I HAS
BEEN TURNING ITS ATTENTION TO
PROVIDING TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
AND SUPPORT. FOR THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF HEAT ARE WE DO
A WEEKLY OFFICE HOURS WHICH IS
ACCESSIBLE TO THE CEO SEES IN
THE LARGE CITIES -- TO PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE -- A LAST
WEEK ARE -- FOCUS ON AUTHENTIC
YOUTH ENGAGEMENT BEGAN -- AND
ALLOWS US TO PROVIDE CONNECTIONS
TO EXPERTS AND MODEL PROGRAMS
FOR ADDRESSING YOUTH
HOMELESSNESS AND OTHER SERVICES.
THANK YOU HELLO.
TURNING NOW TO LESSONS LEARNED
FROM HEAT.
IT'S CLEARLY EARLY DAYS FOR THE
PROGRAM BUT THERE ARE STILL A
FEW LESSONS THAT I THINK OF
CONTRIBUTED TO THE SUCCESS OF
THE PROGRAM.
AND OUR SUCCESS AND DISBURSING
THE FUNDS SO QUICKLY.
FIRST THE AUTHORIZING STATUTE
WAS CLEAR AND PROVIDED GUIDANCE
BUT WAS NOT TOO PRESCRIPTIVE IN
THE MAJOR PROGRAM STRUCTURE
ELIGIBLE APPLICANTS AND USES AN
ALLOCATION FORMULA PROVISIONS.
IT ALLOWED US TO MOVE AHEAD
QUICKLY AND AT THE SAME TIME
GAVE US ENOUGH FLEXIBILITY TO
MAKE THE SPECIFIC DECISIONS THAT
INEVITABLY ARISE IN DEVELOPING
AND IMPLEMENTING A NEW PROGRAM.
SECOND WE DELIBERATELY SET OUT
TO MAKE THE PROGRAM IS SIMPLE
TRANSPARENT AND STREAMLINED AS
POSSIBLE WITHIN I ALWAYS ON HOW
WE COULD MAKE THINGS AS EASY AS
POSSIBLE FOR THE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS.
WE TOOK THE FLEXIBILITY TO HEART
WHILE ALSO WORKING HARD TO
ENSURE SUFFICIENT GUIDANCE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY.
THIS IS WHY RECEIVED OUR FIRST
APPLICATION AS WELL HELLO
MENTIONED UP APPLICATIONS TO
FROM OAKLAND AND SAN DIEGO ON
THE SAME DAY THAT WE ISSUED THE
NOTICE OF FUNDING AVAILABILITY.
AND WHY ALL THE APPLICATIONS
WERE SUBMITTED IN ROUND.
ONE THIRD WE TOOK PARTNERSHIP
SERIOUSLY OF THE THREE POSITIONS
AUTHORIZED TO DEVELOP AND
IMPLEMENT HEAP ONE IS LAW HELLAS
POSITION THAT OF A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT LIAISON.
WHOSE PRIMARY ROLE IS TO DEVELOP
AND MAINTAIN RELATIONSHIPS WITH
THE CITIES COUNTIES AND
CONTINUUM'S OF CARE.
AND PROVIDE INFORMATION AND
SUPPORT IN IMPLEMENTING KEEP.
DURING THE APPLICATION PERIOD
THE HEAP TEAM SPENT A LOT OF
TIME DOING PRESENTATIONS AND
WEBINARS ACROSS THE STATE
HOLDING WEEKLY OFFICE HOURS AND
ANSWERING EMAILS AND CALLS.
THROUGHOUT THE APPLICATION
PERIOD THE TEAM ALSO PROVIDED
ONE ON ONE SUPPORT AND DIRECTING
GAUGE MEANT WITH LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS.
WHICH WAS POSSIBLE BECAUSE THAT
WAS NOT A COMPETITIVE PROGRAM.
LET HELL AS SHE MENTIONED A FEW
MOMENTS AGO CONTINUES TO HOLD
WEEKLY OFFICE HOURS IN WHICH ALL
CITIES COUNTIES AND CONTINUES OF
CARE CAN CALL IN TO DISCUSS ANY
TOPIC -- WITH BOTH THE STAFF AND
THEIR PEERS.
AND FINALLY WE KNOW THE WORK IS
NOT OVER AS Là HELEN MENTIONED
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THE REAL
SUCCESS OF THE PROGRAM MEANING
THE FUNDS ARE USED EFFICIENTLY
AND EFFECTIVELY.
AND MAKE REAL PROGRESS IN
ADDRESSING HOMELESSNESS WE ARE
SHIFTING QUICKLY INTO PROVIDING
SUPPORT AND TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
WORKING WITH GRANTEES TO
ESTABLISH GOOD REPORTING PROCESS
SEES.
AND MONITORING PERFORMANCE OVER
TIME.
CONSISTENT WITH OUR OVERALL
APPROACH WE WILL ENGAGE IN THESE
ACTIVITIES WITH THE CONTINUED
COMMITMENT TO PARTNERSHIP.
FOCUSING ON HOW WE CAN ASSIST
GRANTEES IN ACCOMPLISHING THEIR
GOALS AND MAKING A DIFFERENCE IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES.
I WANTED TO TURN BRIEFLY TO THE
QUESTION OF DATA REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS AS THAT SOMETHING
THAT WE HAVE BEEN -- FOCUSED ON
RECENTLY IN THE KEEP
IMPLEMENTATION.
OF THE HEAP STATUTE REQUIRES THE
CITIES AND CONTINUUM'S OF CARE
TO SUBMIT TO ANNUAL REPORTS AND
ONE FINAL REPORT.
THE DUE DATES OF THESE REPORTS
ARE JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AND SEPTEMBER THIRTIETH.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE
INFORMATION REQUIRED BY STATUTE
FOR THESE REPORTS IS CONTRACT
EXPENDITURES.
THE NUMBER OF HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS SERVED BY PROGRAM
FUNDS AND PROGRESS TOWARD STATE
AND LOCAL HOMELESS TO SCHOOLS.
STATURE ALSO AUTHORIZED AGENCY
TO REQUEST ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION TO MEET REPORTING OR
AUDIT REQUIREMENTS.
IN IMPLEMENTING THE PROGRAM WE
HAVE EXPANDED THE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS BEYOND THE LANGUAGE
IN STATUTE.
AND ALL HE'D CONTRACTS SPECIFY
THE GRANTEES MUST PROVIDE THIS
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION.
WE'VE WORKED REALLY HARD TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE DATA WE GET IS
WHAT WE NEED TO MEASURE THE
IMPACT OF HEAP ON HOMELESSNESS
WITHOUT IT BEING OVERLY
BURDENSOME ON JURISDICTIONS.
MOST OF THE INFORMATION THAT
WE'RE GOING TO REQUIRES
CURRENTLY COLLECTED IN THE LOCAL
HOMELESS MANAGEMENT INFORMATION
SYSTEMS.
WE'RE IN THE PROCESS OF
DEVELOPING THE ACTUAL REPORTING
FORM THE GRANT RECIPIENTS WILL
USE.
BUT I WANT TO JUST HIGHLIGHT
SOME OF THE CATEGORIES THAT WE
WILL BE COLLECTING DATA ON IN
ADDITION TO CONTRACT
EXPENDITURES WILL BE REQUESTING
INFORMATION ON THE AMOUNTS
AWARDED TO SUB GRANTEES AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL.
BY ACTIVITY IN PROGRAM TYPE SO
FOR EXAMPLE RENTAL ASSISTANCE --
RAPID RE HOUSING OF ANOTHER KIND
SHELTER BED STREET OUT REACH
PERMANENT HOUSING.
IN ADDITION TO THE NUMBER OF
HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS SERVED WILL
BE ASKING FOR THE NUMBER OF
INSTANCES OF SERVICE PROVIDED.
WILL ALSO BE ASKING FOR
INCREASES IN CAPACITY FOR BOTH
EXISTING AND NEW PROGRAMS.
AS WELL AS THE NUMBER OF ON
SHELTERED HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS
BECOMING SHELTERED AND THE
NUMBER OF HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS
ENTERING PERMANENT HOUSING.
WE'LL ALSO BE ASKING
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT THE PROGRAMS
FUNDED WITH THE 5% HOMELESS
YOUTH SET ASIDE.
AND THE ALIGNMENT BETWEEN KEEP
FUNDING PRIORITIES AND HOUSING
FIRST PRINCIPLES.
WE'LL BE POSSIBLE NGUYEN WHERE
POSSIBLE WERE ASKING FOR THIS
INFORMATION -- BY SUBPOPULATION.
WE BELIEVE THE DATA COLLECTED
THROUGH PEOPLE PROVIDE A
SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNT OF VALUABLE
INFORMATION TO INFORM THE
COUNCIL THE ADMINISTRATION IN
THE LEGISLATURE.
HE PROGRESS REPORTS AND OTHER
HEAP DATA COLLECTED WILL BE
AVAILABLE PUBLICLY IN ON OUR
WEBSITE BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU FINANCE.
NOTHING TO ADD WE JUST BE HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
LL.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
APPRECIATE -- HEY YOU'RE
MENTIONING DATA AND AND METRICS
AND A GLOBAL QUESTION I HAVE --
HAS TO DO WITH THE FACT THAT AS
A STATE IN AND CERTAINLY ALL THE
JURISDICTIONS AROUND CALIFORNIA
WE HAVE SPENT BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS TRYING TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS.
WITHOUT A LOT OF METRICS OF WHAT
IS REALLY WORKING AND I WANTED
TO ASK YOU -- DO WE HAVE ANY
BASELINE OF METRICS I KNOW
YOU'RE TRYING TO COLLECT.
DATA ON THE FIRST HALF BILLION
DOLLARS WE HAVE WE'RE GONNA
SPEND HOPEFULLY ANOTHER AT LEAST
HALF BILLION DOLLARS OR MAYBE
SIX HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS.
HOW SHOULD WE THINK ABOUT
METRICS YOU HAVE WHAT DATA WE
CURRENTLY HAVE AND THEN WHAT
DATA YOU THINK WE SHOULD BE
CAPTURING SO THAT WE CAN?
REALLY PROVIDE SOME GUIDANCE TO
LOCALS AND AND CEO SEES TO HELP
US -- ADDRESSES BECAUSE I THINK
WHAT WE ALL WANT WE WE WERE.
THERE'S A REAL GENEROSITY OF OF
OF SPIRIT WHEN IT COMES TO WHAT
WE'RE WILLING TO SPEND IN THE
BUDGET BUT I THINK WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT OUR DOLLARS ARE
BEING WELL SPENT.
ABSOLUTELY THOSE THAT'S GREAT
QUESTIONS -- SEE IF I CAN
ADDRESS THEM ALL -- NO CURRENTLY
WE ARE CHALLENGED BECAUSE WE
DON'T HAVE A STATE LEVEL
BASELINE OF DATA ON HOMELESSNESS
AS YOU KNOW -- BOTH IN TERMS OF
DEMOGRAPHICS AND CHARACTERISTICS --
AND ALSO IN TERMS OF SERVICES
THAT ARE USED IN ANY GAPS IN
SERVICES -- THERE IS A
SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNT OF DATA
COLLECTED IS YOU KNOW AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL IN THE CONTINUES OF
CARE.
AND THAT DATA GETS TRANSMITTED
UP TO THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
ANNUALLY AND AND THEN HI -- THE
US DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
URBAN DEVELOPMENT ISSUES -- A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT REPORTS THAT
CAN BE BROKEN DOWN NOT ONLY TO
THE STATE LEVEL BUT ALSO TO THE
INDIVIDUAL CONTINUE WITH CARE
LEVEL SO THAT DOES PROVIDE US
WITH THE DATA THAT THAT FRANKLY
WE'RE RELYING ONCURRENTLY IN
OUR IMPLEMENTATION -- THE
COUNCIL STAFF HAS BEEN IN AN IN
AN EXPLORATORY PHASE OF LOOKING
AT DEVELOPMENT OF A STATE LEVEL
HOMELESS.
INTEGRATED DATA SYSTEM THAT
WOULD ALLOW US ACCESS -- TO TO
THE DATA THAT'S CURRENTLY BEING
COLLECTED AT THE LOCAL LEVEL --
THAT AS I SAY IS IN SORT OF THE
MARKET RESEARCH STAGE AND WE'VE
BEEN WORKING CLOSELY WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY -- ON
SORT OF THE DEVELOPING WHAT THAT
MIGHT LOOK LIKE AND I THINK ONE
THING I WOULD SAY IS -- IT I AM
FAMILIAR WITH THAT --
CIRCUMSTANCE IN LAST YEAR'S YOU
KNOW I'D A BILL TO TRY HIM FOR
THAT CONCEPT WHICH I KNOW THE
ADMINISTRATION POLICING CONCEPT
SUPPORTED -- THREE OF US OUR
COLLEAGUE IS MOVING THAT SAME
BILL FOR THIS YEAR BUT IT IS MY
HOPE THAT IN THIS BUDGET.
WE CAN MAKE A COMMITMENT TO THIS
BECAUSE IF WE'RE GONNA BE
SPENDING AT LEAST HALF A BILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR WE NEED TO KNOW
WHAT THE MONEY IS BEING USED FOR
AND IT IS INCREDIBLY IRONIC THAT.
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS ARE SENDING
THAT DATA TO THE FEDS BUT WE
DON'T HAVE THAT DATA HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WE NEED TO RECTIFY
THAT SO.
MUCH HOPE -- IN THE BUDGET
PROCESS TO ANYONE IS LISTENING
THAT WE CAN FIGURE THIS OUT THIS
YEAR WE DON'T HAVE TIME TO WASTE.
AS FAR AS THE OF THESE GIRLS AND
THEY REACHED OUT QUITE A BIT FOR
HELP.
ABSOLUTELY HELLO CAN SPEAK TO
THAT -- IN MUCH MORE DETAIL BUT
IT'S AN ONGOING CONVERSATION ON
GOING -- WE HAVE THE OFFICE
HOURS EVERY WEEK WHICH THE
MAJORITY OF THEM PARTICIPATE IN --
THEY'VE REQUESTED YOU KNOW ONE
ON ONE IN PERSON SO I'VE
ATTENDED MEETINGS WORKSHOPS I'VE
MET WITH CITY MANAGERS -- BAY
AREA CO SEES TO HELP.
YOU KNOW TO HELP THEM WITH THE
APPLICATION PROCESS AND THEN
WITH YOU KNOW ENGAGEMENT AND
COLLABORATION SO THEY'RE VERY
VERY ENGAGED.
IN ONE BENEFIT IF I COULD JUST
ADD TO THAT IS THAT FOR EXAMPLE
WHEN WE NEED ACCESS TO
INFORMATION -- FROM THE
CONTINUUM OF CARE BECAUSE OF THE
RELATIONSHIP THAT'S BEEN
ESTABLISHED WE GET A VERY GOOD
RESPONSE RATE WHICH IS REALLY%
HELPFUL TO US IN TRYING TO GET
AN EARLY SENSE OF HOW
IMPLEMENTATION IS IS GOING.
SO I THOUGHT ABOUT THE DATA YOU
CLICK TO FOR THE HEAT PROGRAM --
I WISH A LOT OF OTHER PROGRAMS
WOULD DO THAT.
WE'RE PUTTING MONEY TOWARDS IT
BUT WE WANT TO BE EFFECTIVE --
IN THE MONEY WE'RE PUTTING
FORWARD SO HOPEFULLY WE CAN
ANALYZE THAT DATA.
AND COME OUT WITH SOMETHING GOOD
BY ONE OF THE HE WAS PRETTY FOOT
SENIOR STAFFER BEING ENGAGE WITH
OUR STAFF.
BECAUSE BOTH OF THE GREAT JOB --
THIS POINT OPEN UP TO PUBLIC
COMMENT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU KAYLA WHICH
SPEAKS OF A CLOSE PUBLIC COMMENT.
I AM ROOM THIS IF THIS IS THE
INFORMATION ONLY ITEM FINANCING
ONE ISSUE NUMBER.
TWO THAT'S THE HOMELESS YOUTH
ACT IMPLEMENTATION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS CARE
MEMBERS DANIELLE BRANDON
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THE
HOMELESS YOUTH ACT OF TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN ARE SB EIGHT
NINE EIGHTEEN REQUIRES THE
HOMELESS COORDINATING AND
FINANCING COUNCIL. TO WORK WITH
OTHER STATE ENTITIES TO DEVELOP
AND COLLECT DATA.
ON A COUNTY LEVEL BASIS TO SEEK
OUT DATA AND COORDINATE WITH
YOUNG PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS.
AND THE BUDGET ASKS THREE
HUNDRED NINETY EIGHT THOUSAND
I'M SORRY THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY
NINE THOUSAND DOLLARS.
AND TWO POSITIONS TO EXPAND THE
HOMELESSNESS CORNING FINANCING
COUNSEL TO IMPLEMENT SB.
NINE EIGHTEEN BE HAPPY TO TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS [inaudible]
WELL. TO THE FULLEST WITH THE LA
A WE HAVE NO ISSUES TO RAISE ON
THIS ITEM.
THE QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
I'M GOING TO PUT A PUBLIC
COMMENT.
CAN LOS REPRESENT COLLEGE VIçT
ON A CO SPONSORS OF SB NINE ONE
IN OUR PLACE TO SUPPORT THE
EXPANSION OF STAFF AND WHATEVER
ELSE THEY MAY NEED TO ENSURE
THAT WE CAN IMPLEMENT SB NINE
ONE EIGHT APPROPRIATELY ENSURE
WE CAN.
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE NOT
HOMELESSNESS ESPECIALLY TO THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
THERE IS A CERTAIN SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF BOTH -- C. S. H. AND
HOUSING CALIFORNIA.
MUCH SHORTER COMMENTS THIS TIME --
AS TO THE CO SPONSORS OF SB NINE
EIGHTEEN WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
ADDITIONAL STAFF OF THE COUNCIL
TO FULLY IMPLEMENT THE DUTIES
ASSIGNED AND ASKING MY MONEY
THANK YOU.
A GOOD AFTERNOON SHERILYN ADAMS
LARKEN STREET AND SEE SEE WHY
AND IN SUPPORT AS WE SUPPORTED
NINE ONE EIGHT AND CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT THE WORK OF THE COUNCIL
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
TAMMY MARTIN ONCE AGAIN ON
BEHALF OF EQUALITY CALIFORNIA
ALSO ONE OF THE CO SPONSORS OF
SB NINE ONE EIGHT LAST YEAR I'M
JUST BRIEFLY STATING SUPPORT FOR
THE STAFFING INCREASE SO THAT
THE HOMELESS YOUTH ACT OF TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN CAN REACH ITS
FULL POTENTIAL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THE
RECOMMENDATION IS TO PROVE HIS
BUDGET IS OUR MOTION.
AS A CO AUTHOR OF SB NINETEEN
HAPPENED MAKE THAT MOTION.
ROLL CALL PLEASE COOPER HI
[inaudible]
TWO LACKEY [inaudible]
NAZARIAN.
NEXT MOVE ONTO A ISSUE NUMBER
FOUR REGIONAL HOUSING NEEDS
ALLOCATION PROCESS.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS MY NAME'S DANIEL
CRISTIAN WITH THE DEPARTMENT
HOUSING COMMITTEE OF ELEMENT
FISCAL MANAGEMENT BRANCH --
THAT'LL SAID THAT THE RECORD FOR
HOUSING POLICY IT CITY.
SO THE REGIONAL HOUSING NEEDS
ALLOCATION ALSO KNOWN AS THE
RINA PROCESS DETERMINES AMOUNT
IN INCOME DISTRIBUTION OF
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT CAPACITY THE
CITY AND COUNTY MUST OWN OVER
FIVE SAY YOU'RE PLANNING PERIOD.
IT IS INCLUDING EACH
JURISDICTIONS HOUSING ELEMENT.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY SEVENTY
ONE INCREASES TRANSPARENCY IN
THE RENO OCCASION PROCESS AND
PROVIDES JURISDICTIONS IN THE
GENERAL PUBLIC ACCESS TO MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT HOW RENO
OCCASIONS ARE CALCULATED.
SENATE BILL EIGHT TWENTY EIGHT
AS WITH ALL THE REVIEW
pRENO PROCESS.
IN EACH CITY IS REQUESTING TO
POSITIONS TO IMPLEMENT AB
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY ONE AND ONE
NEW POSITION TO IMPLEMENT SB.
EIGHT TWENTY EIGHT P. C. REQUEST
SIX HUNDRED THIRTY EIGHT
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN FISCAL YEAR.
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY AND FIVE
HUNDRED AND FORTY THREE THOUSAND
ONGOING FOR THE GENERAL FUND TO
FUND THREE POSITIONS AND WITH
THAT WE'LL BE HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS HERE.
FINANCE.
NOTHING.
L. L..
NO ISSUES TO RAISE ANY QUESTION
COMMITTEE.
GOING UP AND UP OKAY OVER THE
PUBLIC COMMENT.
OKAY HOLD PUBLIC COMMENT.
OF GUT -- OBVIOUSLY IS WHEN
HOMELESS OPEN AND WE VISIT AFTER
MAY REVISION.
THE REASON IS TIED TO ONE OF THE
HOUSING BUBBLE.
LET'S MOVE ON HONOR FIVE CD CD
BG DISASTER RECOVERY PROGRAM.
ON AUGUST TWENTIETH TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THE US DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND URBAN DEVELOPMENT
ANNOUNCED AT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WILL RECEIVE TWO
HUNDRED TWELVE MILLION TO
SUPPORT LONG TERM RECOVERY.
MITIGATION EFFORTS RELATE TO THE
OCTOBER AND DECEMBER TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WILDFIRES.
FUNDS WERE APPROPRIATED FOR BOTH
A MINUTE RECOVERY NEEDS AND
MITIGATION ACTIVITIES AS FOLLOWS.
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FOUR MILLION
FOR UNMET RECOVERY NEEDS AND
EIGHTY EIGHT MILLION FOR
PREPAREDNESS AND MITIGATION
NEEDS.
THE THIS BUDGET CHANGE BOZELL IS
TO REQUEST POSITION AND BUDGET
ALREADY TO OVERSEE THE
DISTRIBUTION OF HUNDRED TWENTY
FOUR MILLION AND I'M AT RECOVERY
NEEDS PORTION OF THIS FEDERAL
GRANT.
SPECIFICALLY EIGHTY REQUEST ONE
HUNDRED EIGHT MILLION.
I AM FISCAL YEAR TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETY OR NINETEEN TWENTY AND
TWO POINT FIVE MILLION ON GOING
FROM THE FEDERAL TRUST FUND TO
FUND TEN POSITIONS.
THE DESIGN AND IMPLEMENT THE
DISASTER RECOVERY PROGRAM
FOCUSED ON IT RECOVERY NEED.
AND WITH THAT WE'LL ANSWERING
QUESTIONS YET FINANCE.
L. L. ISSUES TO RAISE ANY
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE.
KELP NOT PUBLIC COMMENT.
JERRY HOLD PUBLIC COMMENT I HAVE
A QUESTION WHAT PROCESS WILL AC
TAKE TO NOTIFY LEGISLATURE THAT
ADDITIONAL EIGHTY EIGHT POINT
TWO MILLION.
THEN RECEIVED FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
AND YOUR FRIEND WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WE HAVE
VARIOUS -- ADMINISTRATIVE
MEASURES THAT WE CAN TAKE I'M
ONE OF THEM IS CONTROL SECTION
TWENTY EIGHT WHICH REQUIRES
NOTIFICATION TO THE JAIL BC WE
ARE WAITING FOR NOTIFICATION OF
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
BEFORE WE CAN DO ANYTHING.
THANK YOU OTHER RECOMMENDATIONS
OF PROVES BUDGET IS OUR MOTION
SO.
ROLL CALL PLEASE COOPER HI Q..
LACKEY [inaudible]
AARON [inaudible]
WITH.
WAS THE SYSTEM NUMBER SIX
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE.
SO THE STATE'S COMMITMENT TO
PROVIDING AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR
MIGRATORY AGRICULTURE WORKERS
AND THEIR FAMILIES TO THE OFFICE
OF MIGRANTS SERVICES PROGRAM
BENEFITS NOT ONLY CENTER
RESIDENTS BUT ALSO THE STATE'S
ECONOMY AS A WHOLE.
MANY OF CALIFORNIA SPECIAL CROPS
FOR ME LABOR INTENSIVE DURING
PEAK HARVESTING PERIODS WHICH
CREATES GREATER PRESSURE FOR
LOCAL HOUSING SMALL AGRICULTURAL
RURAL AREAS OF CALIFORNIA.
THIS HOUSING DEMAND USUALLY FAR
EXCEEDS THE EXISTING RULE
HOUSING SUPPLY THIS FARMWORKERS
AND THEIR FAMILIES ARE REQUIRED
TO FIND ALTERNATIVE LESS
DESIRABLE MEANS OF TEMPORARY
HOUSING WHILE WORKING IN THE
AREA.
THESE ALTERNATIVES OFTEN RESULT
IN AND SANITARY AND SAFE HOUSING
CONDITIONS FOR WORKERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES.
THE CITY IS REQUESTING A THREE
MILLION DOLLAR GENERAL FUND
APPROPRIATION FOR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE TO ADDRESS THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY DEFICIENCIES
AT STATE OWNED AGRICULTURAL
MIGRANT HOUSING CENTERS
[inaudible]
FINANCE.
NOTHING THAT L. L. NEW ISSUES TO
RAISE ANY QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE.
ANY COMMENTS WITH PUBLIC.
AND SOME OF THE QUESTION IS A
PLAN FOR THE ADDITIONAL DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE ON THE FARM WORKER
HOUSING.
SO I MARK DIVERS -- DEBBI
ACTING TO PROJECTOR FINANCIAL
SYSTEMS AND IT IS OUR INTENT TO
START CONTINUE WORKING WITH
PARTNER FINANCE ON THEIR CAPITAL
OUTLAY BUDGET -- FOR NEXT YEAR
TO ADDRESS THE REMAINING ITEMS.
THANK YOU OUR RECOMMENDATIONS TO
PROVE HIS BUDGET.
IS OUR MOTION.
SEC ROLL CALL PLEASE COOPER HI
JUNE [inaudible]
LACKEY [inaudible]
NAZARIAN [inaudible]
WICKS -- WHAT OTHER NUMBER SEVEN
HOUSING ELEMENT WORK WILL
ADJUSTMENT?
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
RECOGNIZE THE AVAILABILITY
AVAILABILITY OF HOUSING IS A
MATTER STATEWIDE CONCERN
CALIFORNIA'S BATES A POPULATION
FIFTY MILLION BY TWENTY FIFTY
ADEQUATELY
OF NEW HOUSING.
FURTHER CALIFORNIA'S HIGH
HOUSING COSTS AND LACK OF
HOUSING SUPPLY COMPROMISES THE
ABILITY TO ACCESS OPPORTUNE
ACCESS OPPORTUNITIES SUCH AS
JOBS HELP STABILITY FOR FAMILIES
AND INDIVIDUALS INCLUDING
WORKING FAMILIES AND PERSONS
WITH SPECIAL NEEDS.
EIGHTIES ROLE IMPLEMENTING STATE
HOUSING LAWN INVOLVEMENT AT
LOCAL REGIONAL STATE LEVEL IS
KEY TO EFFECTIVELY ACHIEVING THE
STATE'S HOUSING GOALS.
REVIEW OF LOCAL HOUSING ELEMENTS
INSURERS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
ADEQUATELY PLAN TO ME EXISTING
AND PROJECTED HOUSING NEEDS IN
PRIORITIZE INVESTMENTS AND
HOUSING FOR VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS.
IN ADDITION RECENTLY PASSED
LEGISLATION EXPANDS HE SEES ROLE
AND NOT JUST REVIEWING BUT
ENFORCING JURISDICTIONS
COMPLIANCE WITH THEIR OWN
HOUSING ELEMENTS. EIGHTY REQUEST
ONE POINT THREE MILLION IN
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY ONE POINT
TWO MILLION ONGOING FROM THE
GENERAL FUND. FOR AN ADDITIONAL
EIGHT HOUSING OWN REVIEW
POSITIONS TO EXPAND AND ENHANCE
ITS HOUSING ELEMENT REVIEW
ENFORCEMENT FUNCTIONS FOR THE
UPCOMING SIX CYCLE HOUSING
ELEMENT REVIEW PERIOD
ANTICIPATED TO BEGIN IN.
TWENTY NINETEEN AND WHAT THAT
WILL ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU
FINANCE.
WORKING AT PHILADELPHIA.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE.
THE COLOR OF THE PUBLIC.
THE RECORD RECKLEZZ APPROVES
BUDGET -- THEIR MOTION.
SO.
ROLL CALL PLEASE COOPER HI.
TO LACKEY [inaudible]
MS ERIN.
WICKS.
IT WAS SIX THIS ISSUE EIGHT
ORGANIZATION DEVELOPMENT AND
STRATEGIC PLANNING AND THE CITY
ORGANIZATIONAL DEVELOPMENT
STRATEGIC PLANNING UNIT ALSO
KNOWN AS ODIOUS P. LEADS
CONSULTS AND ADVISES ADVISES
INTERNAL BUSINESS PROCESS
INNOVATION.
TEAMS TO IDENTIFY CRITICAL
CONSTRAINTS AND BOTTLENECKS THEY
IMPEDE THE PROCESS AND IMPACT
CUSTOMERS AND STAKEHOLDERS.
THE AREA'S PT MEMBERS FOCUS ON
PROBLEM SOLVING ROOT CAUSE
ANALYSIS PINPOINT IDENTIFICATION
AND DEPLOYMENT OF DATA DRIVEN
SOLUTIONS THAT CAN BE QUICKLY
IMPLEMENTED.
THE TEAM IDENTIFIES HIGH IMPACT
LOW EFFORT SOLUTIONS TO DEPLOY
FIRST TO ADDRESS THE LARGEST
BOTTLENECKS IN THE PROCESS.
EASY REQUEST FIVE IN A SIXTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS IN FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY AND
500-050-01000.
FIVE ANNUALLY THROUGH TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION -- FOR MYSTERY
BUDGET AUTHORITY FOR FOR
POSITIONS TO PRINT ANYTHING I
WISH THE ODIOUS P. UNIT.
THIS UNIT WILL CONTINUE TO
IMPLEMENT THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
STRATEGIC PLANNING GOVERNANCE
BPI PROJECTS ENTERPRISE RISK
MANAGEMENT AND ORGANIZATIONAL
CHANGE MANAGEMENT MANAGEMENT
TRAINING.
IN BUT THAT WILL ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE FINANCE.
YEAH KHALIL NEW ISSUES TO RAISE
ANY QUESTIONS WE COMMITTEE.
A PUBLIC CAMILLUS ITEM.
OKAY WE LOST OUR QUORUM SO.
WE'LL GO AHEAD AND HOLD THIS FOR
NOW.
LET'S MOVE ON AND I'M
[inaudible]
PARDON.
WE DO MOST OF START OKAY.
WE HAVE A THREE STAR MICHELIN.
THANK YOU SIR NO DISRESPECT
MEANT.
OKAY ROLL CALL PLEASE.
COOPER HI.
TO I LACKEY.
NAZARIAN.
WICKS.
WAS TEXAS TUITION OR NINE NO
PLACE LIKE HOME.
THE NO PLACE LIKE HOMEPROGRAM
WAS ESTABLISHED TO DEVELOP
PERMISSIBLE OF HOUSING FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE IN NEED OF
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES AND ARE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS OR AT
RISK OF CHRONIC HOMELESSNESS.
IN ORDER TO EXPEDITE THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF NO PLACE LIKE
HOME PROGRAM MEASURES PLACE ON
THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN NOVEMBER
GENERAL ELECTION BALLOT.
NO PLACE LIKE HOME ACT OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN ALSO KNOWN AS
PROPOSITION TWO AND WAS
SUBSEQUENTLY APPROVED BY THE
VOTERS.
THE NO PLACE LIKE HOME PROGRAM
ALLOWS FUNDS TO BE PROVIDED
DIRECTLY COUNTIES WITH AT LEAST
5% THE STATE'S ALMOST POPULATION
AS DEMONSTRATED IN THE HOMELESS
POINTING COUNT.
BASED ON THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN
POINT TIME CAN'T RESULTS
ELIGIBLE ALTERNATIVE PROCESS
COUNTIES ARE LOS ANGELES SANTA
CLARA SAN DIEGO AND SAN
FRANCISCO.
IF YOU THE REQUEST SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND LOAN --
FROM WHICH FOR IN THE GENERAL
FUND LOAN FOR CASH FLOW NEEDS
FOR THE NO PLACE LIKE HOME
PROGRAM UNTIL PROGRAMS BONDS CAN
BE ISSUED IN THE FALL OF TWENTY
NINETEEN WITH THAT WILL ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS.
FINANCE.
NOTHING THAT L. L..
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
A PUBLIC COMING THIS ITEM.
EVERYONE HAS BEEN PATIENTLY
WAITING FOR THE NO PLACE LIKE
HOME PROGRAM.
THIS PROPOSAL FACILITATE MOVING
THE FUNNY QUICKER THE
COMMUNITIES THAT NEEDED.
THE RECORD WAS TO PROVE HIS
BUDGET IS OUR MOTION.
SHE LOOKS SECOND.
ROLL CALL PLEASE.
COOPER HI TO LACKEY AYE NAZARIAN.
WICKS.
BUT THAT'S THE NUMBER TEN CAL
HOLD TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE.
THE CAL HOME PROGRAM PROVIDES
GRANTS TO LOCAL PUBLIC AGENCIES
AND NONPROFIT DEVELOPERS THIS IS
FIRST TIME HOME BUYERS TO
DEFERRED PAYMENT LOANS FOR DOWN
PAYMENT ASSISTANCE HOMEY ABILITY
ASIAN.
SELF HELP HOMEOWNERSHIP AMONG
OTHER ACTIVITIES THIS TRAILER
BILL WOULD EXPAND THE PROGRAM
USES TO INCLUDE SAYS REDRAWING
UNITS AS AN AUTHORIZED USE.
ALLOW FOR PROGRAMS TO SERVE
MOTOR INCOME HOUSEHOLDS IN
DISASTER AREAS.
WITH THAT WILL ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
NOTHING NOTHING AT LL.
SHE'S TO RAISE ANY QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE.
I'LL TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT.
REMEMBER DAVE JOB HALF CITY
SANTA ROSA WE APPRECIATED RIGHT.
AFTER FROM.
GETTING RECOGNIZED FOR FUNDING.
SO WE APPLAUD THE MOVE THE
COMMITTEE AND AND ENJOY THE
TROUBLES.
THANK YOU THE RECKLESS TO STOP
PLACEHOLDER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE IS OUR MOTION THE BILL.
SEC.
ROLL CALL PLEASE COOPER HI TO
LACKEY HI THERE IN.
WICKS.
ISSUE ELEVEN LOCAL HOUSING TRUST
FUND TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE.
THE LOCAL HOUSING TRUST FUND
PROGRAM PROVIDES MATCHING FUNDS
TO LOCAL HOUSING TRUST FUNDS
THAT ARE FUNDED ON AN ONGOING
BASIS WITH PRIVATE CONTRIBUTIONS
ARE PUBLIC SOURCES.
THAT ARE NOT OTHERWISE
RESTRICTED IN USE FOR HOUSING
PROGRAMS ELIGIBLE RECIPIENTS
INCLUDE CITIES AND COUNTIES WITH
ADOPTED HOUSING ELEMENTS.
THAT EACH CITY HAS A TRIMMING
COMPLY WITH HOUSING ELEMENT LAW
INSURABLE NON PROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS.
THIS PROPOSED REAL BILL WILL ADD
NATIVE AMERICAN TRIBES OF ELGIN
APPLICANTS INCREASE THE MINIMUM
SIZE OF AWARDS IN PHILLY
OBSTACLES OBSOLETE LANGUAGE
RELATED TO THE PROBLEMS HE
PROGRAM [inaudible]
FINANCE.
NOTHING THAT L. L..
NO ISSUES TO RAISE QUESTIONS FOR
THE COMMITTEE.
GOING UP IN A PUBLIC COMMENT.
SEE WE HAVE ONE SPEAKER.
NICOLE WATERMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS WE ARE SUPPORTIVE OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCES --
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE ON THE
LOCAL HOUSING TRUST -- ONLINE IT
DOES INCLUDE THE INCLUSION OF OF
BUILDING HOMES AND JOBS ACT
FUNDING AS A LOCAL MATCH AND SO
WE ARE SUPPORTIVE OF THAT WE ARE
ALSO REQUESTING FLEXIBILITY TO
PERMIT.
AN HSA A FUNDING AS WELL AS LAND
AS A LOCAL MATCH THANK YOU THANK
YOU THE RECTAL SET UP THE
PLACEHOLDER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE IS THERE A MOTION
[inaudible]
SOME OF WELL MOTIONS SECOND ROLL
CALL PLEASE COOPER HI TO LACKEY
AYE AYE THIS AREA.
ISSUE NUMBER TWELVE DEVELOPMENT
A COMPLIANCE MONITORING
AUGMENTATION [inaudible]
THANK YOU
.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR.
IN THE AFTERNOON I AM ANTHONY
ZERO ON THE DEPUTY -- WE ARE --
REQUESTING THREE POSITIONS TO
ADDRESS ONGOING.
INCREASED -- WORKLOAD --
SPECIFIC -- TO INCREASED --
PROJECTS AND JUST TO ADDRESS THE
INCREASE INCREASING WORKLOAD
[inaudible]
FINANCE -- NO CONCERNS.
LA UP EMISSIONS TO RAISE ANY
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE.
THE NURSE WAS THE PUBLIC WISHING
TO SPEAK ON THIS ITEM.
OKAY THE RECKLEZZ ADOPT THE
SPRING FINANCE LETTER THEIR
MOTION [inaudible]
CHECK IT.
ROLL CALL PLEASE COOPER HI.
TO LACKEY AYE AYE NAZARIAN
[inaudible]
WICKS.
IT IS A DRUG ISSUE NUMBER
THIRTEEN LOCAL ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT PLEASE ON SERVICES
.
THIS WILL RESTART.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS.
NAMES JENNIFER HAYNIE CAM THE
BUDGET OFFICER FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF BUSINESS
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT.
HIS NAME.
OR GO BEST.
GO VISIT HER QUESTING THE FORTY
OF A HUNDRED AND FORTY THOUSAND
AND ONE POSITION IN FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY NINETEEN AND TWENTY AND
I'M GOING TO ADDRESS THE
REQUIREMENTS SB [inaudible]
SIX THIRTY FIVE FINANCE
[inaudible]
LL.
A FRIEND WITH A FOR THE BRAIN
WHETHER FORD WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
WITH NO COMMENTS.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS ITEM.
OKAY RECKLEZZ TO PROVE HIS
BUDGET IS OUR MOTION.
ROLL CALL PLEASE.
HI -- TO LACKEY HI HIS ARIAN.
WICKS.
THE MOTION PASSES FIVE THOUGH --
ISSUE FOURTEEN FOR ALL I'M SORRY.
A PERFORMANCE IMPROVEMENT
INITIATIVE ENTER THE BILL
LANGUAGE FOR UP ALL LICENSE FEES
.
WELCOME THE TROUBLES WITH.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE --
CHECK ABOUT WILL SMITH'S RECTOR
OF THE DEPARTMENT BUCKLE
COVERAGE CONTROL I WANT TO JUST
GIVE YOU ABOUT NINETY SECONDS ON
THE BACKGROUND OF HOW WE GOT
HERE WITH THE TO ISSUE ITEMS WE
HAVE.
THAT'S OKAY.
SURE IN CASE WE ARE FOUNDED BY
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT IN --
NINETEEN FIFTY FIVE TO BE THE
EXCLUSIVE REGULATORS OF THE
MANUFACTURE DISTRIBUTION.
AND SALE OF ALCOHOL.
WE HAVE ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED AND
FIFTY NINE EMPLOYEES AND TWENTY
FOUR OPC OFFICE LOCATIONS AROUND
THE STATE.
ABOUT 45% OF US ARE SWORN PEACE
OFFICERS WE HAVE NINETY TWO
THOUSAND BUSINESSES THAT WE
LICENSE WERE COMMITTED TO PUBLIC
SAFETY.
PREVENTION AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT WE HAVE VERY GOOD
RELATIONSHIPS WITH OUR INDUSTRY
STAKEHOLDERS.
LOCAL POLICE AND GOVERNMENTS AND
PREVENTION GROUPS UNFORTUNATELY
WE DO NOT HAVE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO BE ABLE TO
GIVE THEM THE SERVICE THAT THEY
DESERVE.
OUR ENFORCEMENT COVERAGE IS --
DWINDLING IN TERMS OF ITS --
PRESENCE AROUND THE STATE AND
THAT'S JUST PARTLY A FUNCTION OF
SHEER NUMBERS WE HAVE WE HAVE
THE SAME NUMBER OF SWARM PEACE
OFFICERS WE HAD NINETEEN FIFTY
FIVE AND WE HAVE ABOUT THREE
TIMES AS MANY PEOPLE IN THE
STATE AND MORE THAN DOUBLE THE
NUMBER OF LICENSEES.
I'M IN TERMS OF THE SERVICES WE
PROVIDE TO OUR CUSTOMERS -- WE
HAVE NO ABILITY TO ACCEPT
ELECTRONIC PAYMENTS SO WE
PROCESS A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND PAPER CHECKS EVERY
SINGLE YEAR.
WE HAVE NO ABILITY TO ACCEPT
ONLINE APPLICATIONS OR DOCUMENTS
ELECTRONICALLY PEOPLE UP THE
MAILMAN OR COME INTO OUR OFFICES
IN HAND TO US -- OUR INDUSTRY
FOR YEARS HAS BEEN SAYING THAT
IT ISWITH SUPPORT TO FEE
INCREASE IF WE CAN PROVIDE THEM
WITH THE SERVICES THEY WANT.
AND OVER THE PORT.
BUT THE COURSE OF THE PAST YEAR
WE WORK FOR THE DEPRTMENT OF
FINANCE TO LOOK AT THE
DEPARTMENT IN ITS MISSION. TO
RIGHT SIZE THE DEPARTMENT TO
FIGURE OUT WHETHER WE WERE DOING
THINGS WE SHOULDN'T BE OR WE
WEREN'T DOING ENOUGH OF WHAT WE
SHOULD BE.
AND WHAT WE CAME UP WITH WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WAS
THE PROPOSALS THAT WE HAVE --
BEFORE YOU TODAY -- THEY THEY DO
TWO THINGS THEY ESSENTIALLY FIX
THE STRUCTURAL DEFICIT WE HAVE
WHICH DEVELOPED BY THE BY VIRTUE
OF THE FACT WE RAN A SURPLUS --
APPROXIMATELY FIVE YEARS AGO AND
WE'VE BEEN SPENDING THAT MONEY
DOWN SINCE THEN.
AND THE REMAINDER THE INCREASES
TO FUND OUR MODERNIZATION
EFFORTS WHICH IF APPROVED BY THE
COMMITTEE IN THE LEGISLATURE
BECOME LAW WILL RESULT IN OUR
LICENSE HE'S PAYING ABOUT 10%
MORE.
THAN THE OTHERWISE WOULD TO WHAT
WE HOPE TO BE A DRASTICALLY MORE
RESPONSIVE -- DEPARTMENT TO THEM.
SAID TURNING ON TO THE ISSUES --
NUMBER ISSUE FOURTEEN PROGRAM
PERFORMANCE IMPROVEMENT
INITIATIVE.
IS A MULTI YEAR PLAN TO
STRENGTHEN MODERNIZE THE
DEPARTMENT ORDERED PROVED FOR
PROVE OUR SERVICES TO THE PUBLIC.
I'M INTO THE INDUSTRY REGULATE.
THE PROPOSAL REQUEST THIRTY FOUR
POSITIONS AND FIVE MILLION TWO
HUNDRED AND FORTY NINE THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN FISCAL YEAR.
NINETEEN TWENTY AND A TOTAL OF
FIFTY ONE POSITIONS -- GROWING
TO A TOTAL OF FIFTY ONE
POSITIONS AND SEVEN MILLION.
FOUR HUNDRED SIXTY NINE THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN THE FOURTH YEAR OF
THE PROPOSAL WHICH IS.
TWENTY TWENTY TWO TO TWENTY
TWENTY THREE THERE'S A TRAILER
BILL ACCOMPANYING THIS PROPOSAL
THAT -- WAS SENSUALLY CHANGER
FEES STRUCTURED TO BETTER
ALLOCATE THE FEES ON THE
APPLICATION SIDE THAT WE
ACTUALLY -- GENERATE WORKS TO TO
JUSTIFY SO ESSENTIALLY
RECOVERING OUR ACTUAL COSTS OF
PROCESSING THOSE APPLICATIONS.
AND THEN OUR RENEWAL FEES THE
RUPEES OUR LICENSEES PAY EVERY
YEAR WHICH GO TOWARDS OUR
ENFORCEMENT COMPLIANCE EFFORTS
THOSE WOULD BE STRUCTURED IN A
WAY THAT WOULD WOULD CREATE.
FEES SIMILAR FOR LICENSEES WERE
OF SIMILAR RELIGIOUS.
HAPPEN ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
L. L..
HOW INCREASING AT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE WE
DON'T HAVE ANY SIGNIFICANT
CONCERN FOR THE PROPOSAL --
CLEARLY THERE'S SOMETHING IS TO
BE DONE WITH THE WITH THE FEE
STRUCTURE BECAUSE OF THE
SIGNIFICANT -- FUND CONDITION
ISSUES AND I'M IT DOES SEEM LIKE
THE OTHER I REQUEST A RIP
PROPORTIONS THE REQUEST A
REASONABLE WE JUST KNOW THAT
GIVEN THE SCALE AND STE AND
NATURE OF THIS REQUEST IT'S
PRETTY FAR REACHING -- THE
LEGISLATURE MAY WISH TO CONTINUE
TO KIND OF MONITOR THE
DEPARTMENTS IMPLEMENTATION OF
THIS TO MAKE SURE THAT -- THE
EGG BUT PROMISED.
BENEFITS ARE ACTUALLY ACHIEVED
THANK YOU FINANCE.
CHARLIE MANNING DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE -- I JUST WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THAT FINANCE HAS
WORKED CLOSELY WITH ABC FOR A
YEAR AND A HALF TO DEVELOP THE
PROPOSAL. TO ENHANCE THE
SERVICES ABC PROVIDES AND
ADDRESS THE STUFF STRUCTURAL
DEFICIT OF THE ALCOHOL BEVERAGE
CONTROL FUN.
AND THE EFFORT TO FILL INCREASED
LICENSING AN ENHANCEMENT TO
MAN'S IS WARRANTED AND AFTER
CAREFUL CONSIDERATION -- WE FEEL
THAT THE PROPOSAL TO INCREASE
FEES IS THE BEST APPROACH TO
ADDRESS THE LONG TERM HEALTH OF
THE FUN.
THANK YOU FOR ABC HOW DO YOU
PLAN TO ASSESS AN ONGOING BASIS
THE IMPACT THE CHANGES BEING
PROPOSED -- WELL WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO BE MONITORING FOR
EXAMPLE ON THE ENFORCEMENT SIDE --
ESSENTIALLY HOW LONG IT TAKES US
TO ACTUALLY INVESTIGATING CLOSE
OUR COMPLAINTS ON THE NUMBER OF
MINOR OF MINOR DECOY OPERATIONS
WE RUN -- WE CAN MONITOR BY --
ASSESSING.
ON THE NUMBER OF IMPACT
INSPECTIONS ANOTHER PROACTIVE OF
OCT -- ACTIVITIES OF OUR AGENTS
ON THE LICENSING SIDE -- WE
WOULD ESSENTIALLY BE ASSESSING
THE AMOUNT OF TIME IT TAKES US
TO PROCESS PROCESS AN
APPLICATION OUR GOAL HAS BEEN
75% -- AND THAT REALLY HAS SLID
DOWN TO ABOUT 50% -- AND THE
LAST COUPLE YEARS SO THOSE ARE
THOSE ARE METRICS WE WOULD HAVE
IN ASSESSING THOSE PROGRAMS A
AND GOING FORWARD WE CAN REPORT
BACK ON LEGISLATURE ABSOLUTELY.
OKAY ANY QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
MRS AREA.
THAT'S THE POINT.
IT'S OUR IT'S ALL GOOD -- I JUST
WANTED TO POINT OUT OF HER SO
THAT YOU YOU JUST TOUCHED ON THE
ISSUE OF THE THE THE THE DECOY --
SURVEILLANCE OR OR BUT PROGRAMS
THAT YOU WOULD HAVE I BEEN ON
ONE ACTUALLY A COUPLE OF NIGHTS --
I THINK IT WORKS GREAT I THINK
IT ALSO HAS A COMPLEMENTARY
EFFECT TO SOME OF THE OTHER --
EFFORT LAW ENFORCEMENT RELATED
EFFORTS THAT TAKE PLACE -- IN IN
STEMMING OUT CERTAIN.
CERTAIN ISSUES THAT MAY BE
STARTING IN CERTAIN PLACES SO --
I'M.
VERY ENTHUSIASTIC AND SUPPORTING
YOUR EFFORTS AT THIS HAS BEEN A
CONVERSATION FOR SOME YEARS AND
THE SUBCOMMITTEE.
AND AND AT SOME POINT THERE WAS
ALSO AN IMPORTANT.
AUGMENTATION MADE IN ORDER TO
MAKE SURE THAT YOU HAVE -- THE
PERSONAL THAT YOUR HIRING STAY
WITH THE DEPARTMENT AS WELL.
A GIVEN THE SHORT LIFE SPAN THAT
SOME OF THE OFFICERS WERE
STAYING AND THEN MOVING ON SO --
HAPPY TO SUPPORT AS THIS --
ISSUE MOVES FORWARD AND THANK
YOU FOR WHAT YOU'VE BEEN DOING
THANK YOU SORT OF PAUSE RIGHT
NOW BECAUSE THIS WEEK'S HAS TO
GET BACK TO COMMITTEE.
TO TESTIFY.
I'LL NEVER BILL SO WE'RE GONNA
GO AHEAD AND THE VOTE FOR FOR
VOTE ONLY [inaudible]
MR LACKEY [inaudible]
LACKEY [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
NAZARIAN [inaudible]
HI.
ISSUE NUMBER.
ONE LACKEY.
HI WICKS HI.
ISSUE NUMBER THREE WICKS HI.
ISSUE NUMBER FIVE WICKS.
ISSUE NUMBER.
SIX THE GOOD BUSINESSES ARE IF
YOU WERE SICK OKAY.
THIS NUMBER SEVEN WICKS.
ISSUE NUMBER [inaudible]
EIGHT TO FIVE WICKS.
ISSUE NUMBER NINE TO FIVE THREE
WEBSITE.
SHE NEVER TEND TO BUY WEBSITE.
ISSUE NUMBER ELEVEN TO NINE
WICKS.
THIS NUMBER TWELVE WITH.
THIS NUMBER.
THIRTEEN SO BACK TO MISTER.
TO I JUST WANT TO TAKE THE
OPPORTUNITY -- TO TO SAY I AM
VERY GLAD THAT -- THERE'S A LOT
OF THINKING ABOUT HOW TO MOVE
THE A. B. C. FORD AND I'LL JUST
SAY THIS -- WITHOUT -- THIS IS
NOT A SHOOT THE MESSENGER MOMENT
BUT I THINK WITH.
WITH THE EXCEPTION THE DMV I GET
MORE COMPLAINTS ABOUT THE
FAILURE OPERATIONS AT THE A. B.
C. THAN VIRTUALLY ANY OTHER
STATE AGENCY I CAN THINK OF AND
I HAVE BEEN AWARE THAT I THINK
THE LACK OF RESOURCES IS REALLY
IMPINGED YOUR ABILITY TO DO THAT --
BUT CERTAINLY WHEN IT COMES --
TO THE CHALLENGES THAT SMALL
BUSINESSES ARE HAVING IN
ACCESSING.
SERVICES FROM THE ABC -- THE
FACT YOU DON'T HAVE ANY ONLINE
SERVICES THESE ARE ALL THINGS
THAT YOU KNOW ALL THAT BEING
SAID I'M VERY OPEN TO SUPPORTING
THIS PROPOSAL BUT I WILL WANT TO
KNOW MOVING FORWARD THAT IF
THESE RESOURCES ARE COMING DOWN --
THAT WE'RE GONNA SEE A REAL
CHANGE AND HOW ARE CONSTITUENTS --
PARTICULARLY OUR SMALL BUSINESS
CONSTITUENTS ARE ARE DRESSED SO
JUST WANTED TO SAY THAT IT'S AN
ONGOING CONVERSATION AND DID
WANT YOU TO BE SURPRISED IF IN
THE YEAR TWO I'M STILL THIS
COMMITTEE AND IF WE KEEP GETTING
THESE COMPLAINTS WITH ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES I HAVE A LOT MORE
QUESTIONS.
OPEN UP PUBLIC COMMENT.
CLOSE PUBLIC COMMENT.
IN THE PAST A. B. C. DO NOT HAVE
ADEQUATE RESOURCES AND
ENFORCEMENT STAFF TO CARRY OUT
THIS MISSION.
CHANGES IN THE LAST FEW YEARS
HAVE IMPROVE THE HIRING AND
RETENTION OF ENFORCEMENT AGENTS.
THIS REQUEST MAKES OTHER CHANGES
TO FURTHER INCREASE THE NUMBER
OF ENFORCEMENT AGENTS.
IMPROVE LACKS LICENSEE PROCESSES
IN THE OPERATIONS OF ABC
ELIMINATE THE OPERATING DEFICIT
FRIDAY GREATER LEVEL FUNDING FOR
THE DEPARTMENT.
THESE CHANGES ARE FOR GOVERNOR
THE TO MAKE A POSITIVE IMPACT ON
THE ABC.
SUBCOMMITTEE WHAT TO ASSESS THE
IMPACT IS THE CHANGES AND THEIR
EFFECT ON PERFORMANCE OVER TIME.
AND WANT TO CONSIDER ADDING TO
THE TRAILER BILL REPORTING
LANGUAGE THAT REQUIRES REPORTING
OF PERFORMANCE METRICS IN TWO
YEARS AND AGAIN A FIVE YEARS.
WELL AS A LOT OF OPEN THANK YOU.
WHICH BRINGS US TO OUR LAST ON A
MISSION -- FOR FIFTEEN BUSINESS
MODERNIZATION RESPONSIBLE
BEVERAGE SERVICE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THE
DEPARTMENT SEEKS TO MODERNIZE
ITS EXTERNAL INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY SERVICES TO BETTER
SERVE THE PUBLIC IN ITS INDUSTRY
STAKEHOLDERS.
THERE INITIALLY TO STE DISTINCT
PROJECTS INVOLVE THE SERVICES
AND RBS RESPONSIBLE BEVERAGE
SERVICE -- THESE TWO HAVE BEEN
COMBINED GIVEN COMMON STRUCTURAL
ELEMENTS RESULTING COST SAVINGS
AND RISK REDUCTION.
THE DEPARTMENT IS SEEKING FIVE
POINT FIVE POSITIONS AND TWO
MILLION DOLLARS TWO MILLION NINE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY TWO THOUSAND
DOLLARS AND TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY ODD TO FUND THE FIRST
YEAR OF THIS PROJECT.
AND THEN WE'LL COME BACK FOR
MORE SPECIFIC REQUESTS FOR THE
FOLLOWING FISCAL YEARS ONCE WE
HAVE OUR PROCUREMENT --
COMPLETED AND BETTER ESTIMATES
IS THE FOR THOSE COSTS.
THANK YOU LL.
I WE DID HAVE A COUPLE OF QUICK
COMMENTS AND QUITE OF
RECOMMENDATIONS THE FIRST IS WE
WOULD NOTE THAT THIS PROJECT
HASN'T YET COMPLETED THE FULL
POWER PROCESS THE PROJECT
APPROVAL LIFECYCLE PROCESS WHICH
IS THE NEW I. T. U..
R. PROCESS THAT WAS IMPLEMENTED
A FEW YEARS AGO SO IT'S JUST
COMPLETED STAGE TWO OUT OF FOUR
STAGES -- ACCORDINGLY I THE
PROJECT DOESN'T HAVE A REFINED
COST ESTIMATE AT THIS POINT --
WE THINK THAT THIS MEANS THAT
REALLY THE LEGISLATURE -- HAS A
LITTLE BIT OF A A DIFFICULT TIME
UNDERSTANDING THE FULL COST OF
THE PROJECT AT THIS POINT AND SO
WE'RE RECOMMENDING BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE THAT WOULD CONDITION
THIS FUNDING ON THE COMPLETION
OF THAT FULL PROBLEM HELP
PROCESS -- SECONDLY JUST WANTED
TO FIGHT FOR THE LEGISLATURE
THAT -- RESPONSIBLE BEVERAGE
COMPONENT -- SERVER COMPONENT --
ORIGINALLY WHEN THAT WENT
THROUGH THAT WAS -- IN RESPONSE
TO A BILL THAT WAS PASSED IN THE
ORIGINAL COST ESTIMATE WAS
SIGNIFICANTLY LOWER SO JUST
WANTED TO FIGHT THAT FOR FOLKS --
I CERTAINLY IT SEEMS REASONABLE
TO HAVE THIS IT COMPONENT BUT
BUT IT WASN'T ORIGINALLY
ENVISIONED WHEN THE BILL WENT
THROUGH.
THANK YOU FINANCE.
I JUST WANNA KNOW THAT FINANCE
ASSESSES EACH PROJECT ON A CASE
BY CASE BASIS AS A PART TIME AND
IF BUDGET BILLS OF LANGUAGES
NECESSARY WELL PROJECT IS STILL
IN THE POWER PROCESS.
AND PART OF THE INTENT OF THE
POP PROCESSES THAT ESTIMATIONS
OF PROJECT COST AND SCHEDULE
APPROVED DURING STAGE TWO ARE
FAIRLY ACCURATE.
AND POLICY IN THE STATE
INFORMATION MANAGEMENT MANUAL
ESTABLISH A THRESHOLD DURING
STAGE FORM THAT I PROJECT CANNOT
MOVE FORWARD OR COSTS AND ARE
NOT WITHIN 20% OR FIVE MILLION
WHICHEVER IS LESS OF STAGE TWO
ESTIMATES.
SO IN THIS CASE -- DO THE WORK
COMPLETED BY ABC DURING THE
MARKET RESEARCH AND PLANNING
PHASES.
IN MINISTRATION FELT THAT ONE
YOU'RE FUNDING -- IS APPROPRIATE
TO AVOID POTENTIAL DELAYS.
AND BASED ON ABC'S RESEARCH ON
CURRENT TRES TRENDS IN THE RBS
TRAINING MARKET -- WE THOUGHT
THAT ESTIMATES IN THE STAGE TO
DOCUMENTATION ARE REASONABLE.
AND ONCE A. B. C. COMPLETE STAGE
FOR IN THE FALL OF TWENTY
NINETEEN ABC CAN REQUEST FUNDING
FOR SUBSTANCE QUITE YEARS
THROUGH THE ANNUAL BUDGET
PROCESS.
AND THE LEGISLATURE WILL RECEIVE
NOTIFICATION OF FINAL COST WHEN
THE PROJECT IS APPROVED.
THANK YOU A QUESTION FIRST
MISTER APPLE SMITH -- HOW YOU
SURE THE TRAINING FEE CHARGE OF
SERVERS IS NOT EXCESSIVE?
SO THE TRAINING FEE THEY WERE
CHARGING THE SERVICES NOTHING
OTHER THAN A COST RECOVERY --
IT'S JUST BUDGETED DIRECTLY
TOWARDS OUR COST OF
ADMINISTERING THE EXAM SO
ACCOUNTING PROCEDURES TO ENSURE
THAT THE MONEY RECOVERING IS
USED -- THE MONEY FOR THE FEES
IS USE IN FACT FOR THAT PROGRAM
IT WILL THAT BE -- RIGHT NOW OUR
ESTIMATE IS ABOUT THREE DOLLARS
AND TWENTY FIVE CENTS -- THE
VARIABLES FOR US WOULD BE OF
COURSE THE COST PROCUREMENT ALSO
THE SIZE OF THE POOL OF THE
APPLICANTS BUT THREE TWENTY FIVE
IS OUR IS OUR BEST ESTIMATE AS
OF THIS DAY.
OKAY THANK YOU THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF AB TWELVE
TWENTY ONE WILL HELP ENSURE THAT.
TO ENSURE SERVERS ARE
KNOWLEDGABLE ABOUT THE STATE LAW
AND REGULATIONS RELATED TO
ALCOHOL BEVERAGE CONTROL THE
IMPACT OF ALCOHOL IN THE BODY.
THE SUBCOMMITTEES WE WANT TO
ADOPT TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO
ENSURE THAT FEES CHARGED TO
SERVERS.
THE GOAL OF THE TRAINING OR NOT
EXCESSIVE.
THE WHOLE SIDE OPEN.
THESE ARE HEARING THANK YOU CAN
YOU